good morning everyone we'll be starting
minute
okay good morning ladies and Gentlemen
let's get started and welcome to the
January 9th meeting of the science
technology and energy committee as is
our custom I'd ask you all to rise and
pledge pledge allegiance to the flag of
the United States of America
and to the Republic for which it stands
one nation under God indivisible with
all okay so this morning we have two
public hearings
scheduled at 9 and 9:30 then we will
follow that with a full committee work
session on five bills that we heard
yesterday starting
at whenever we finish the two public
hearings and then this afternoon at 2
o'clock we're going to have an executive
session on the five bills that we heard
yesterday at 1:00 there will be a
republican caucus in this room so no one
will be allowed in the room except
members of the Republican caucus of
St so be aware of that as you make your
plans we hope to break for lunch around
11:30 qu to 12 and then as I said we'll
be back here for a caucus at 1:00 and an
exec session at 2 so with that we can
open the festivities here this morning
by opening a public hearing on House
Bill 61 uh 1617 dfn relative to energy
procurement agreements for default
service and I call on the prime sponsor
of this legislation representative JD
Bernardi to introduce the bill to the
committee good morning and
welcome good morning thank you Mr chair
uh JD bernardy Rockingham 36 Hampton
Falls Kensington Southampton Newton and
plastow um so
I I I'm
uh opening this discussion on HB
1617 uh which is an act relative to
energy
procurement uh agreements for default
service and what this bill does is ADD
reasonable price stability is one of the
criteria for default service the others
being provide a safety net assure
Universal act access and system
integrity and what it focuses on is
Energy service
contracts uh that the power or the power
supply agreements uh that the utilities
enter into by requiring them to consider
varying length and terms of contracts
potentially lading those and having them
reviewed by the Pu on a quarterly basis
contracts being shortterm meaning 3 to
six months medium-term 6 to 12 months or
long-term 12 to 18 months in duration
but no specificity of how many have to
be in what uh of what flavor it's it's
uh it's basically their assessment of
what will get to reasonable price
stability now this bill is really a
placeholder bill it's it arose after a
working session uh of late last year
um in that working session we indicated
we were awaiting the Doe's report on
this subject matter that report is not
yet issued it's still a placeholder uh
but they are here to testify on options
to make it better
um I want serious input uh from the doe
the Pu the utilities from rate payers
and other interested parties to improve
this bill and make it the best possible
um the desire here is really to remove
that 30 30 plus perc risk premium that's
associated with current uh contracts
largely the natural gas
contracts uh to clo to get our rates
closer to Market rates which should
provide greater
stability ideally it would have blunted
that huge doubling Spike we saw in July
of
2020 um
if the utilities were looking at rates
on a quarterly basis at a minimum and
had an opportunity to take some of that
risk uh premium out of their their
contracts so again I'm looking for
further ideas to improve this bill to
make it a better bill so that we can in
a working session uh come up with an
amendment so uh for advancing this bill
in the future
um and with that I'm open for any
questions uh but I'm really looking for
those that follow me to give their
ideas okay thank you representative
Bernardi for introducing that bill as
representative Bernardi said
he introduces this bill
so that we can begin a good conversation
about the subject and we have the Public
Utilities Commission we have the New
Hampshire Department of energy we have
eversource and we have the office of the
consumer Advocate all scheduled to
testify here so I humbly suggest that we
try to restrict our questions to
representative Bernardi so that we can
have maximum time to get input from
these other uh entities but with that I
will recognize representative Doug
Thomas for a question thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question so to
be clear on the bill being a
placeholder uh is it an attempt um to
allow the utilities to become more
flexible in perhaps grabbing an
advantageous market price when they see
it coming versus being restricted to a
time element that that makes them to be
locked into a price that they would
otherwise would like to be
lower yes that's exactly the focus uh
right now contracts are let every six
months in a very short time window and
whatever the market price and the risk
premium associated with that is is what
they are stuck with and what we're stuck
with if if we allow for greater
flexibility in that Contracting schedule
uh ideally we'll take uh some of that
system representative reyolds has a
question thank you Mr chairman um I'm
noting your the section where you the
last section that's bolded where you say
um permitting a mix of short medium and
long-term contracts and in parenthesis
you say the duration so longterm 12 to
18 months do you mean who say that the
longest term contract you
envision uh utilities entering into is
18 months or is that are you open to is
that intended to be sort of binding as
the longest term contract allowed or was
that just example no it's not intended
to be the longest longest term I like
like I said I'm I'm open for uh for
improvements to this and if uh
if some utility identifies a source
that's five years of you know two cents
a kilowatt hour jump on it thank you I'm
that okay seeing no other questions for
representative Bernardi I'd like to next
call on Alex spidel from the Public
Utilities
Commission good morning Mr spel and
again good morning Mr chair thank
you I have some prepared remarks that
I'd like to read from first if
possible certainly thank you thank you
for the opportunity to address the
committee with some thoughts regarding
this bill from the commission's
perspective I'm Alexander spidel a
senior adviser at the New Hampshire
Public Utilities Commission I first
became associated with the Commission in
the commission believes that this bill
while well intentioned in light of
recent events in the energy markets
would cause more harm than good for New
Hampshire rap
payers as a matter of principle it is
better for the legislature to leave some
matters open-ended for the commission to
determine as time goes on based on the
facts and circumstances at hand through
our judicative
processes this is such an area as time
has gone on the wholesale energy markets
New England have matured and are
starting to bear fruit for
consumers in recent weeks the commission
has approved significant decreases for
default service also called Energy
Service rates for the energy Supply
customers of the state's three
investor-owned Electric
utilities the overall Bill reductions to
be effective on February the 1st range
from about 10% to the high teens and the
reduction in the the energy component
alone ranges from 25% to
33% these are major savings which will
apply for the upcoming February through
July 6th month rate
cycle these savings are also on top of
the last rate Cycles reductions which
applied from August of last year through
the end of this month of
January the reason that New Hampshire
default service customers are enjoying
these savings is because new Hampshire's
default Service rates are Market
reflective in that they adjust every 6
months in response to the prices offered
by wholesale Market suppliers for their
supply
contracts there is no lading or staging
of these contracts out of time so
consumers pay prices that roughly
correspond to the prevailing energy
market conditions in New
England now after the energy Market
Panic of early 2022 has subsided New
Hampshire rape payers taking Energy
service from their utilities are able to
enjoy the downward swing in prices
without undue delay or what economists
term price
stickiness commissioner Elms of the
Department of energy will give more
details about how this Dynamic has given
better outcomes for New Hampshire than
for our Southern New England neighbors
like Massachusetts which do apply the
lattering concept
the commission after its i22 d53
investigation is currently exploring
having more direct access to the
wholesale electricity markets by New
Hampshire utilities and providing
default service which could offer even
more potential for savings by reducing
transaction costs and having even more
Market reflective prices while
maintaining the stability of having a
six-month rate cycle for households and
small businesses
our investigation data does indicate
that true wholesale prices in New
England are much lower than prices
offered through wholesale requirements
contracts a correlation that has held
true over the last several
years the imposition of lading and other
such prescribed approaches would
severely blunt the commission's ability
to assess and potentially direct
implementation of improvements to
default service procur M approaches
going forward and potentially hamstering
the ability of New Hampshire consumers
to fully benefit from Market reflective
pricing Dynamics in the
future I thank the committee for your
consideration of these remarks and I
welcome questions from members of the
committee thank
you thank you questions from the
committee representative Harrington has
a
question thank you Mr chairman and thank
you uh for taking my question nice to
see you again
um my question is this I I believe and
tell me if I'm wrong that the commission
already has the authority to set various
lengths of times for contracts if they
deemed that that was appropriate and
with that flexibility they could change
how the contract's lengths were going to
be much quicker than having to go
through a legislative process to do that
so you could more accurately reflect
what was going on in the market is that
correct uh in a general uh term Mr
representative yes I would say that if a
regulated utility wanted to adjust its
contract lengths or the length of its
procurement cycle it could make a
proposal to that effect to the
commission and the commission would
assess that in an adjudication and
that's currently existing within our
framework to have the capability to
adjust those settlement agreements and
adjust those approaches right now thank
you representative Thomas has a question
dou Thomas that is thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question um I
understand what you're saying and under
good times of stability in the world uh
it probably works best but in this world
things are not going well and they and
they not go well quickly there
are faster things happening and response
times are are severely shortened what
there what then could you
recommend like the process you just uh
mentioned would take time I assume to
you know redo the contract and so forth
and and by that time the the um ability
to grab a a a a good price might go away
my concern um overall is the bad effects
it has on our residents when you have a
huge price spike that they haven't
planned for most people have budgets and
even though they might pay a slightly
higher price if it's the same all the
way all the way through they can adjust
okay but when it spikes badly that's
when you know you get complaints they
get hurt so what do you recommend then
that we could do to avoid those High
spice prices that are going to happen
again because the world is changing
quickly up and down it's not going to go
back um Mr representative I would say a
few things u i will allow commissioner
Elms to expand on a little bit of what
happened in Massachusetts but the data
shows that they eventually did get the
2022 price spike reflected in their
rates it was a little bit of a time
delay perhaps due to lading but they
ended up higher up than New Hampshire
ended up and the delayed reaction has
taken longer time to correct itself down
to the lower pricing level so
202022 uh those two years were very
unusual with the pandemic obviously the
industrial
shutdowns prices in the energy markets
crashed and then they corrected there
was inflation there was the war in
Ukraine that resulted in a lot of
concerns about supply for Western Europe
for East Asia and the Market's
overcorrected a little bit but things
have stabilized there seems to be uh I
would say the market has responded
around the world to the Natural Gas
markets and the energy markets generally
have responded to the understanding that
we can have alternative Supply sources
from
Russia and to have Market reflective
prices is important because it if there
is real scarcity for example if there
were time situation and there was real
scarcity of energy it's important to
send that signal to Consumers to respond
appropriately if there's true scarcity
so there's a variety of reasons that
complete amelioration of price spikes is
not always the right answer and it's
better to allow things to adjust
naturally on their own in a reasonable
help representative Gman has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you Mr
spidel for taking my
question as is with each of the three
investor owned utilities going out for
contracts every six months what we have
then is six rate cases per year coming
before the Pu with lading it could be
many more is that a concern of the Pu is
just the increased workload on looking
at these rate
cases um I I don't understand uh
necessarily the lattering proposal to
implicate more frequent default service
adjustments Mr representative I think
what would be implicated is uh from our
point of view a concern that it would
result in bad outcomes for consumers
where you would be locked into high
pricing
structures and you would not have a
natural adjustment every six months to
reflect lower prices and so 6 months may
seem like a long time but it's actually
a fairly short time into the energy
markets on a macro level and when you
have requirements contracts being
resubmitted on a six-month cycle the
market participants are quite Nimble in
adjusting to what's going on out in the
world it is true that there is a concern
regarding risk premium uh that is a
different matter of discussion but the
lattering issue has nothing to do with
sir representative right else has a
question thank you Mr chairman because
my my question is a follow on to to my
colleague representative corman's
question even if
um you said that you don't
um his question was basically about the
the workload for the Pu and you you said
you didn't see that this would involve
more frequent rate cases but the the
plain language of of the bills it seems
to put a trem
tremendous additional workload on the on
the commission it's and and and even it
it seems to put the Commission in the
role
of you know taking responsibility for
for Price stability it says you'll
review contracts on a quarterly basis
and permit a mix of short medium and
long contracts that sounds like just
kind of a lot of analytical work uh and
I know you you testified the Pu is
opposed to the bill so I I guess I just
wanted to ask about the the workload
component you may be right about that
sir in that maybe we kind of have a can
do attitude we're a pretty small agency
and we're pretty flat and so we we often
uh take on projects and we don't have
the mindset of fretting about workload
but I think if two representatives are
asking about that question I on some
reflection I think you may have a very
good point there both of you um it may
be if it were to come into fruition it
would require more work than I had Ed
participated so that that's worth the
thought yes thank you representative Ms
has a question thank you thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question U I want to Echo the concerns
of uh representative Doug Thomas um but
from the perspective of businesses in
the state um
uh one of the things that businesses um
look for is some predictability in terms
of what their costs are going to be
going forward and um the current
system creates some pretty significant
uncertainty uh with with you know
significant spikes upwards and downwards
and it makes it very hard to plan out
Investments um the the bill is an
attempt I think to give the
Pu kind of another tool in the in the in
your toolbox to try try to um address
that concern um given your opposition to
the bill are there other tools that we
should be considering to uh provide some
more predictability in the
rates I would answer that uh one of the
issues that the commission sees with the
bill is that it restricts the number of
tools in the toolbox that are accessible
to the commission that it restricts the
discretion of the commission to consider
remedies that are appropriate so to
backfill on your question regarding
business energy use the larger the
business in New Hampshire the more
likely it is that they have electrical
supply the energy component provided
through competitive Supply contracts
that they negotiate on their own through
competitive wholesale energy suppliers
so if you're looking at manufacturing
concerns even medium-sized businesses
like shopping centers and the like they
tend to have those thirdparty contracts
are not involved in default service so
this wouldn't really touch upon them for
the smallest business that find default
service to be relatively convenient
their load profile it can it can be
varying of course but if you're thinking
about a small business such as a
restaurant or a small store it it the
the spikes are of concern but they do
reflect market conditions and one of the
reasons that the legislature directed
the commission about 10 years ago to
finalize
the divesture process wherein we would
be getting energy Supply not directly
from the power plants of the three
utilities but rather uh the competitive
market is that sending the pricing
signals is good to encourage efficiency
but also to enable the consumer to pay
what's out in the market and not an
artificially low or high price and
so I would say that this bill is
problematic because it restricts the
discretion of the commission and also
that it it's not necessarily a bad thing
for folks on default service to see some
adjustments to price to reflect what's
actually going on in the real world
based on natural gas prices based on
other conditions it's uh Market signals
can provide many benefits to individuals
followup followup
um you you've said you know several
occasions that this bill kind of limits
the commission's ability to to take
action I I'm not sure I understand that
I mean the I don't know that the bill at
least the way I read it and maybe you
can point out to me where I'm
wrong I don't think there's anything in
the bill that forces the commission to
only consider lattering op lattering
situations
what it does is
enables um
lading so so what what am I what am I
missing and maybe I'm reading the bill
wrong I would say uh as a point of
interest uh on line six of the version
of the bill I have here before me it
says in order to provide price stability
so um price
stability is in the mix for the various
restructure policy principles that the
legislature enacted first off uh nearly
25 years ago but then reemphasized about
10 years ago with the PSNH
divestiture and it's it's a it's a
phrase that has a specific meaning in
the economic world that says stability
is going to be your prime directive
versus Market reflective prices and then
it goes on to say the commission shall
oversee the timing in terms of energy
service contracts between the regulated
public utilities and energy
providers and shall approve such
procurement dot dot dot using various
lengths and terms and lading so when you
have in New Hampshire traditional
statutory construction when we at the
executive branch agencies read the
legislative enactments when we see shall
and then conjunctive phrases with and we
requirement okay representative Kennedy
has a
question uh thank you Mr chairman and
thanks for taking my question um this is
a little bit of a followup to the
previous question when I read the bill
it it sounds to me like any plan for
lading or whatever would originate with
the utilities and you know it would be
your job to you know oversee that or
approve it or whatever so I mean you you
wouldn't be coming up with lattering
schemes that would be for them although
I'm not sure why they would care too
much to lower their cost but anyway well
that's open to interpretation uh the
commission shall
oversee uh I would say oversight can
implicate different elements but more to
your point the utilities themselves
during our recent
investigation uh most of them I think
all of them actually the investor owned
ones were not very enthusiastic about
Ling's outcomes um some like ever Source
acknowledged that they had been involved
in lading in Southern New Eng with mixed
or less than ideal results and so their
message uh to the commission was we're
not really excited about lading on our
own so it would be a tension where you
have the legislature putting their chips
on the bumper for lading but the
utilities themselves have expressed um
mixed feelings about it at least to the
commission and also the commission would
want to be responsive to what the
legislature wants them to do as we
always
are okay I'd remind the members that we
have several other learned people who
would like to testify this morning
representative Corman has another
question thank you Mr chairman uh so Mr
spidel I'm beginning to understand your
concerns here and I'm wondering if there
is a reasonable way to address them um
as is right now it says the commission
shall review contracts on a quarterly
basis and permitting a mix of short 3 to
six months duration medium six to 12
month duration and long-term 12 to 18mth
duration so the current six-month
contracts actually are part could be
part of that mix six months um it seems
that instead of shall in some cases in
some places in the text um we could have
May so that the utilities May ladder and
the Pu would oversee that but that uh
that the lading would not be required
would that address some of your
concerns I would want to confir with my
colleagues more fully about whatever
final form the language would take under
such a um approach Mr representative but
I would offer this that uh in general
terms it's from the commission's
perspective we have a lot of
broad-ranging authority and we have a
lot of folks before us the utilities the
office of the consumer Advocate the
department of energy other interested
parties
that come before us and are able to
engage in our judicative processes to
come up with solutions that make sense
over time and even if it's softened to a
I would say uh optional or semi-
optional form what what that would do is
again it it tends to um nudge things in
a specific direction that the
legislature might not necessarily intend
or might not necessarily appreciate as
time goes on because it may come up with
bad um outcomes versus the commission
being flexible and within its General
statutory Authority um coming up with
Solutions together with the other
parties to make sure that we're Nimble
and we we can reflect what's going on on
the ground in real time so um I from a
personal perspective I've testified
before the legislature a couple of times
before over the years and I I tend to
shy away from specific language
recommendations I think maybe
commissioner Elms would be better at
that but in a general sense um we we
want to be able to have an open field of
play the way it it's currently exists
possible representative Kaplan has a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you
um for taking my question um you you've
mentioned that lattering has led to bad
outcomes in in Southern New England and
other places that they used it and uh I
just wondered if you you uh I wondered
if you could be more specific about what
those bad outcomes entail and I and I
suppose the follow-up question is do you
not agree that price stability would be
a one of the priorities of the
commission along with the reflecting
Market
forces okay so in the
future yeah okay I'll repeat that
question I I did I did understand the
representative but please go ahead
basically I just wanted could you be
more specific of what those bad bad
outcomes entail using lading in other
places and whether or not price
stability is indeed a priority for the
commission or not so the commission has
a series of directives laid out by the
legislature in the what are known as the
restructuring policy um I would the
restructuring policy principles and also
there is an overall requirement under
our statutes under chapters 374 and 378
for just and reasonable rates and
there's a whole series of elements that
feed into that price stability is one of
the elements that's in the mix it's not
the only element and the reason the
commission has abided by the general
framework um of Market reflective
pricing is because over time yes there
are reversals there are price spikes and
once in a blue moon you may see
something like a price crash such as
during the pandemic year of 2020
but generally speaking over time when
you pull back the camera you see that
the markets generate generally stable
generally favorable pricing outcomes for
consumers so uh price controls have
effects in economics when you look at
either micro or
macroeconomics price controls are
well-intentioned and they often have a
sense of this looks good this could help
out the consumer but it it it it often
happens that instead of allowing the
market dynamics to play out within
guidelines of course when you establish
price controls through lading or some
other means you tend to force up the
spikes farther than you would have had
you allowed the natural flow of the
contract terms to take place and the
reduction in prices that you would
expect after the reversal of a price
bike take longer so that's what the data
show in Massachusetts for instance
that we've actually looked at the prices
over the last couple years in
Massachusetts their eventual Spike was
delayed slightly by one cycle but their
prices ended up going higher than the
New Hampshire energy component prices
and the reversal has taken longer to to
work through so um price controls have
generally a fairly bad track record in
economics um there are wartime
situations like World War II where they
were imposed but they were often um
ignored or shunted around and there was
a black market of course we don't have
that here but they they often end up
having counterintuitive or or the
opposite of result of what you intend
control
um they have a logistical problem to
consider I've received about 15 pink
cards testimony on the next
bill we're well into this uh public
hearing and we still have three
learned persons to hear from so I'm
wondering if I could encourage the
committee to move on and suspend
questions of this uh individual for the
time being would that be po possible all
right I want to thank you Mr spidel your
information has been extremely valuable
and we appreciate you being here but in
the interest of keeping things moving
along I'd like to call Chris Elms from
the Department of energy to speak with
us next thank you Mr chairman and the
members of the committee thank you thank
you
Alex good morning Mr assistant
commissioner and Mr
France thank you Mr chairman and members
of the committee uh for the record my
name is Chris Elms I'm the Deputy
Commissioner of the Hampshire Department
of energy and I'm joined by Tom France
who is our regulatory director um in the
interest of speeding up my testimony I
will say that I share a lot of the uh uh
concerns that Alex raised we are opposed
to this bill uh as written uh we view
the bill as unnecessarily unnecessary
overly prescriptive and inflexible uh
should negative rap hair outcomes arise
um I'll skip through some of the
background on it because Alex did a good
job of laying that out um I did want to
talk talk a little bit about um you know
sort of lading as a strategy or as a
mandate we are not necessarily opposed
to Greater you know lading you know
that's something that we are looking at
in an investigation that we opened
earlier well earlier last year uh and uh
we are in the process of reviewing we
will issue a comprehensive Report with
recommendations and information on a
number of topics related to the
procurement of default service um but I
do want to talk about lading and some of
the issues but why it might not be the
clear answer and I think Alex did a good
job of laying them out but frankly
lading uh most simply put tends to be
more expensive for for customers now
there are potential benefits in terms of
price stability but when you look at uh
the longer contracts that are going to
be entered into as a result of
lading um there are going to be greater
Market risks on those contracts and
consequ quently uh suppliers are either
going to be less likely to participate
meaning less competition and less
obvious less competition means more uh
price for customers or uh they will bid
in a higher risk premium on their bids
which will then be passed on to
customers you know the the the thought
is that if you ladder uh your prices are
going to be uh increasing more uh slowly
but you know once the prices go down
going to go down uh more slowly I did
share with you a chart uh that compares
energy Supply rates paid by eversource
Massachusetts customers and eversource
New Hampshire residential customers uh
from January 2021 to July
2024 um as you can see uh you know from
that chart again this is just the energy
Supply rate so it's not the all-in rate
uh New Hampshire in in uh July of or
August of 2022 saw that that bigger
Spike uh but when you look at the those
42 months in 36 of them New Hampshire
had lower Supply rates than
Massachusetts uh only in six and those
six uh you can see uh were we hire um
that I think does illustrate some of
what we're talking about here that the
risk premiums associated with longer
contracts in a lattering situation are
going to uh just lead to higher costs so
you know representative Bernardi I know
raised you know the question of of
whether or not we should look at uh
adjustments to this structure um you
know and and that question of price
stability versus Market reflective
pricing is an important one for you to
consider I will uh just kind of throw
some some other information out that
that was uh touched on but I I wanted to
reemphasize uh there are currently
alternatives for customers who do value
price stability more than the current
default Service uh structure uh calls
for competitive Supply is an option
consumers today can go onto our website
go to our comparison shopping page for
uh competitive Supply and and find uh
rates that go anywhere from six months
to two years um you'll you'll be able to
see the different prices that go in
there's different terms and conditions
you know we do encourage consumers to uh
you know do their do their research
before entering into any of those things
but there are options for folks who who
uh prefer stability likewise Community
power uh represents an opportunity for
towns who's who want to say that if if
my uh citizens in my town want to you
know emphasize a whole bunch of
different um you know values or or
whatever be it stability price uh
environmental considerations that's an
option for for towns to look into under
the current structure we don't need uh
any statutory changes to have additional
lading um as a matter of fact uh until
2012 uh Unitil uh in New Hampshire used
lading as a as a strategy they uh came
to the commission and asked to move away
from it because the wholesale risk
premiums associated with lading were too
um too expensive for customers and I and
I will say you know I know we all heard
a lot uh in the public when that first
Spike happened in in in August of 2022
uh from consumers and from um you know
folks who were concerned about how
prices went up I I'll just say that when
the reason that you know Unitil uh came
back and and undid sort of what they had
with lading was because citizens uh
constituents would see hey why are our
prices so much higher than they are uh
in neighboring utilities or uh in other
states and the answer was well they they
lad and these um prices are sticky and
they're they're continuing on so I I'll
just say you know you trade one problem
for another and and you know what we see
is that under the current structure
there's flexibility for the commission
and for stakeholders like the department
of energy the OCA the utilities other
stakeholders to weigh in on on that
process and it's a it's a good one um I
also would like to just point out on
that front that um beyond the language
of the bill State Statute under RSA 374
F3 Roman 5 subsection e authorizes the
commission to quote approve alternative
means of providing default service which
are designed to minimize cons customer
risk not unduly harm the development of
competitive markets and mitigate against
price volatility without creating new
deferred costs provided that the
commission finds that such means are in
the public
interest so again um just to sort of
wrap it up there is a reason that this
legislature uh and its wisdom and and
just about every legislature in the
country has created a pu or a Public
Service Commission or a dpu um and and
that's because ratemaking is a complex
process it's timeconsuming it's
iterative iterative and it involves a
lot of collaboration and expert uh work
um it it might not be wise for the
legislature to step into the process uh
on this right now we have an existing
process that has multiple ongoing
reviews from the commission from the
Department of energy um with the
opportunity to find changes and there
are currently available alternatives for
customers who want to value price
stability more than say um the the
current situation would would call for
um obviously legislation is going to be
much more inflexible and less likely for
us to be able to Pivot away from
negative rapair outcome should we arise
um happy to take
questions okay thank you very much I
have a question for you you mentioned
earlier in your testimony that the doe
has an ongoing investigation into this
question yep could you share with us in
any of your findings um particularly
strategies that might work to mitigate
the problems that we saw in uh July of
2022 I'm going to let Tom answer a
little bit more of the specifics but
again you know our Our intention here is
to give a real comprehensive look at the
history for both the legislature for the
commission for other stakeholders uh and
to provide you know some recommendations
and just to highlight some of the
challenges we see with a variety of
yes we we uh hired exitor Associates to
help on this investigation they have a
lot of expertise not just in New England
but across the country um they've they
looked at the pu's investigation they
reviewed that information carefully uh
they interviewed utilities and others uh
concerning their strategies they asked
questions about Alternatives including
even to sending clock auctions with some
experts in the country that do that and
in a couple states such as uh
Pennsylvania and Ohio we have uh a
comprehensive draft that we've been uh
reviewing and I think we're close to
releasing that and we're happy to with
exer to come in and actually go through
that that report in detail with this
committee uh but at this point I think
it's probably just slightly still
premature to give any final
recommendations on that you have an
approximate date when um that study
completed weeks not
months okay thank you other questions
doe well seeing none I guess you guys
did a great
job appreciate your
presentation I have a pink card here
from Michael Lata of ERS Source although
I not not sure I see him in the oh there
he is hiding in the back okay Mr Lata
regular seat you're
up nice job of hiding back
there it's a full
room uh good morning uh thank you for
the opportunity to testify Michael lato
representing uh
eversource
um eversource is is new control on the
bill um as has been
discussed uh you know we are certainly
not opposed to to lading as a uh
strategy to provide um additional
stability in customers energy Supply
rates uh previous uh testifiers had
mentioned that this is a strategy that
um uh we do use which is uh directed by
state law in Massachusetts and
Connecticut um so I would suggest that
if it is the um legislator's intention
uh to move forward with that we we can
certainly accommodate and adjust our
procurement strategies to uh to
incorporate lading uh here in New
Hampshire um I I would suggest um and
just as a refresher I believe the
committee knows but um every six months
we do go out and we procure 100% of the
customers
needs
on default Service uh those rates change
every February and August uh we file um
really the procurement uh RFP with the
commission they make sure that we
properly executed that RFP that we're
prudently selecting the the lowest cost
uh supplier that responded to the RFP
and that is what goes into uh into
customer rates again those who elect to
stay on default Service uh this is a
direct pass through so the utility does
not make any money whatever we um uh get
from the market from suppliers is what
what customers pay for that service um
so the I think there are sort of two
notable changes uh in the
legislation uh the first is a change in
sort of the focus and purpose of default
Service as representative Bernardi
touched upon uh the addition of
reasonable price stability uh would
change um sort of the the focus and and
um uh really the purpose of default
service right now it is supposed to be
uh as closely reflective to the market
as possible uh so again that's that is a
a notable change and I know Mr spidel
and um uh Deputy Commissioner chin
touched Elms uh touched upon how how
that would be uh impactful um the second
piece which is is directing the
commission to oversee the timing in
terms of energy service contracts uh
again if it's the uh wish of the
legislature to move forward with sort of
price stability and lading um we we'd
suggest a little bit of a different
approach uh we'd suggest that the
legislature uh direct the
utilities um or to make it clear that
utilities have the authority to propose
uh lading contracts so not necessarily a
mandate or requirement but making it
clear uh that that is something that the
utilities can do subject to a manner
that is uh approved by the commission uh
I do have some uh Amendment texts that
i' be happy to share with the committee
uh but the approach that we're
suggesting is uh more enabling and
provides a bit more flexibility for the
commission excuse me for the utilities
to propose um uh procurement strategies
for commission approval that of course
other interveners the consumer Advocate
uh the department of energy would have a
role in in reviewing and um uh providing
comment on uh so with that um and I
think that also uh just one final
thought I I know uh representative
Kennedy had sort of touched on you know
the utilities providing the proposals
versus the commission overseeing and I
think that's a little bit more in
keeping with with that approach uh and
so with that I'd be happy to answer
have okay thank you questions from the
committee representative uh parshall has
a
question thank you chair of V uh could
you please thank you for your testimony
today Mr L uh have you submitted this uh
electronically as well uh I I have not I
do have some copies I can share with the
committee if you'd like and of course I
can submit electronically that'd be very
I'd be very interested in seeing the
copy of your suggested amendments so
thank
you representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair uh thank you
for being here and for taking our
questions uh you testified that um by
state law eversource does lattering in
Massachusetts and Connecticut has there
been um have you seen a
beneficial reaction to this for the rate
payers yeah I I I think um the previous
testifiers uh sort of touched on I I'll
say the benefits of of lading as well as
some of the um uh challenges when the
the market prices are rising it's
helpful you'll you'll stay lower longer
because you have uh contracts that are
spread out so customers will not see
those um impacts as soon however in a
falling Market um you do uh stay higher
longer so just you know for example um I
just pulled up up these numbers uh
quickly uh so in Connecticut uh the the
rate is subject to change um or or did
14.71% uh in
Massachusetts uh it's just changed to
17.25 it was at
16.08 and previously
25.7 so again lading in and of itself
does not result in lower rates but sort
of Smooths out the the Peaks and
valleys followup yes thank you
um from ever source's point of view if
some of the states are doing lading
right now wouldn't it be easier if all
of the states did
lading uh no not necessarily as long as
we have clear Direction on how to do the
procurements in each state uh it's it's
something that we do and can
accommodate representative muns has a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you uh for for
testifying
um so um it it we heard previously that
um utilities have broad discretion on
what they can propose and the Pu has
broad discretion on what they can they
can
approve but it sounds like from the from
your perspective
that that discretion doesn't currently
exist is that correct so
um as was previously stated utilities
there there is no state law that
prohibits utilities from from doing
lading U again Unitil was doing up until
fairly recently um we have commission
order that directs Us in the manner in
which we do the procurements the six
months
100% um that was approved coming out of
uh electric restructuring and the
divesture of Our Generation assets so
once we sold off the generation that had
been providing a portion of default
Service uh the commission there was a a
proceeding and the commission you know
ordered us this is how you shall do it
now again that's that can be changed we
could uh offer a different
proposal uh by which we would would do
the uh procurements and the commission
would review that I I would note um and
I I can't recall if Mr spidel touched
upon this but just an example of that
discretion I believe all three of the
investor-owned utilities that are R
regulated in the most recent orders
approving our default Service rates the
commission ordered all of us to provide
plans to them in February having uh 10
to 20% of the procurement being uh
directly from the market from the day
ahead market so you know that's a good
example of of flexibility again
obviously requires commission approval
in order to do that um but the I think
the the point that's made is being made
is there's flexibility in the law but
it's always subject to commission order
and
approval followup um th thank you um and
you know like representative Parell i'
I'd be very interested in and seeing
your amendment can you can you just give
us a Cliffs note version of you know
what that would entail yeah it's uh it's
fairly straightforward I didn't change
we didn't change the uh addition of
reasonable price stability our view is
that's a public policy determination of
the legislature uh and it just says that
utilities have the authority to
competitively procure Electric Supply
through contracts of standard links
entered into with wholesale suppliers at
various times during the year prior
approval representative reol has a
question thank you Mr chair I have a
brief question and then and I'd like a
followup
um um you you stated I think we all we
all understand but you just stated it in
your testimony that um eversource
providing default Energy Service all the
utilities provide energy default service
it it's a pass through of market cost to
Consumers and therefore you don't make
any money on it is it fair to say then
that utilities are indifferent to
whether customers remain on default
service or choose competitive Supply
absolutely by law we have to be
indifferent to it if customers want to
be served by a competitive supplier or
aggregation that is their choice and has
no impact on the utility okay okay then
shouldn't
would would you agree that our message
then to Consumers of all sizes
residential or big
business energy consumers who want more
price stability in their energy
bills uh than is available currently
from default service should choose a
competitive
supplier uh I guess I can't speak for
what the the legislator's message to
consumers would be or should be but I I
will say in uh our messages to customers
we actively promote the opportunity for
them to to shop for competitive Supply
and you know whether it's seeking lower
cost whether it's seeking price
stability there are options available to
them and we try our very best to promote
those options certainly especially when
the prices go way up uh and they're
they're seeking uh a break on their
their costs represent ative McGee has a
question thank you Mr chairman thank you
Mr Lata for taking my question so it
seems as we're going around here what um
we're talking about price stability
we're talking about basically the intent
of the bill and it uh was the result of
a retained bill that we had a
subcommittee on that we worked on last
year and obviously we were doing that in
response to the price spikes and trying
to figure out some solution where we
could say to people that we've tried to
take steps to help um address those
types of spikes but what I'm hearing
here today is that it sounds like we may
be trying to apply the wrong Solution by
saying the Pu shall do this and that
when the Pu already has a mandate to try
and address those types of issues um
based on existing statutory language so
uh would it be your position that the
way we could get at the solution that
we're trying to offer is to is to p pass
a bill that suggests that the
utilities um maybe more actively take
consideration of lading into the
contracts that they enter into in order
to bring
um in order to bring the benefits of
lading if there are any in in the
circumstances where they might apply to
give you the sort of
the not a mandate but uh permission
structure I don't know so I I you know I
I'm not trying to sort of punt the the
question but it truly is a public policy
decision of the legislature of what they
want default service to be so default
service right now in statute is sort of
a social safety net that is available to
all customers to ensure that they have
access to to energy Supply so if for
whatever reason creditworthiness or or
you know whatever it is they can't get
supply from a third party there is
always this this safety net um adding
price stability as one of the goals
along with universal access you know
does fundamentally change what the
product is and how one would go about
procuring it so so if I I would suggest
the legislature the the committee the
legislature you know consider what is
the goal the aim that they want TOA
service to be certainly price stability
is is a noble goal um and you know has
benefits to it as has been discussed you
know sometimes it can be helpful from a
cost perspective sometimes it can be
harmful given where the market prices
are going in the timing of those those
procurements just followup followup can
I just get your input or your thought
around um how the competitive markets
factor into the default service rate and
whether um whether you see comp you know
a truly competitive market as being
maybe more assistance to consumers in
terms of versus
lading um I I think the challenge with
competitive supply has always been
customer awareness and acceptance so
number one that customers are are aware
that these options exist uh and number
two sort of customer acceptance we we
get the questions oh like if I go on
competitive Supply from you know Acme uh
energy who's going to come fix the line
during the storm and you know it's it's
eversource it's still us um and so you
know people are are by Nature skeptical
of change and I think um Mr spidel
talked about the stickiness of of
consumers so you know there are products
uh that are available again you know
Municipal aggregations are one um that
can provide savings can provide longterm
term stability and I think the the
barrier there is is again just awareness
of those as and sort of customer
acceptance of change and there is you
know there there is some risk uh you
know if you enter into a two-year
contract which might seem good at the
start if the market comes down in
default Service rates which again every
six months change comes down you may be
paying a higher price and you know that
consumers all right uh representative
sumers has a question thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question so just so I gather an
understanding uh last year New Hampshire
co-op practiced lading and the where the
utilities could not and the rate
remained about half the price throughout
the year is it just coincidence that by
lading it was half the price of what the
utilities were without lading
so I no longer work at the Electric
Co-op so I'm not going to speak to their
uh procurement practices um they they do
uh they do not while they set their rate
every six months um I I think they
certainly do procure differently um
how they do that the the types of
contracts that they enter into what's
long-term and short-term again I I can't
speak to um I I would
say as I just said to to representative
McGee sometimes it's to the good
sometimes it's the bad um when the rates
change in February we will you know
eversource and and um I think other
investor owned utilities who are rate
regulated will be a little bit lower
than the co-op um so you know it it es
and flows I guess is is what I would
suggest and again I I can't speak to
anymore
okay re representative Thomas Wendy
Thomas has another question thank you Mr
chair quick question um still stuck on
Massachusetts and Connecticut um can you
tell me how long the program has been in
place and is there any talk of repeal
from either of those
States um I will have to check on both
of
those okay seeing no other questions I
want to thank Mr Lata for his
informative
testimony and give the last word as we
very often to to the office of the
consumer advocate so Mr Don cre happy
New Year and welcome again to
stn
it is not on ah now it's on good morning
chairman Vose members of the committee
uh as most of you remember I'm Don Cree
I am the consumer Advocate my job is to
Advocate on behalf of residential
utility customers it's a great pleasure
to testify today and I thank the
chairman for allowing me to bat cleanup
because that means that I don't have to
say very much because I agree with
everything the proceeding Witnesses have
already said and uh my recommendation to
the committee is not to move forward
with this bill and I have eight discret
points that I want to make very quickly
one is that you are thinking of
legislating about default service at an
unusual and I would even argue maybe an
inopportune moment for a couple of
reasons one is that Community power
aggregation in New Hampshire is in the
process of taking flight and there's a
major shift in the default service load
from default service into Community
power aggregation and what that means is
that the companies that uh submit bids
to the utilities to provide default
service are a little freaked out and
their risk premium is likely to be a
little higher than it ordinarily would
be and the other reason I think we're at
a weird time is that this winter marks
the end of the reliability must run
contract for Mystic station and the
pendency of that contract for Fairly
elaborate reasons that I could go into
if you're interested that too has
increased risk premiums uh in the
default service Market that our
customers and other customers in other
states have paid that's coming to an end
in May and I actually think that is one
of the reasons why the price of default
service has taken a welcome decline uh
in the current coming period of February
1 1 to uh July 31st uh Point number two
is in in a perfect world every customer
in New Hampshire would have three
options available to her one would be to
stay on the utilties default service two
would be to be uh participating in their
local community power aggregation
program and three uh uh competitive
suppliers um and you know it's it's kind
of interesting and encouraging to hear
you all thinking about what more we can
do to inform customers about the
availability of competitive Supply and I
would suggest taking a look at Believe
It or Not Texas because the Texas I
think it's the Pu has a really robust
and very userfriendly
website that they use to help customers
find competitive power supply options
that meet whatever their personal needs
are so there's something to consider um
Point number three the Pu if you've been
reading their recent orders about
default service is actively flirting
with the idea of moving part of the
default service portfolio into the spot
Market as the residential rate payer
advocate in the state I am very leery
about that the spot Market is a very
scary place to send residential utility
customers because it is pretty volatile
now the Pu is talking about a pretty
small percentage of the default service
load going into the spot Market but
still I'm pretty skeptical and that
leads into Point number four which is my
sense and I've been consumer advocate
for a fairly long time now is that
residential customers really like price
stability that's important to most of
them very few residential customers want
to ride the wave of volatile wholesale
electricity prices and because price
stability is an imperative for
residential customers there always is
going to be a risk premium because price
stability by definition transfers risk
away from the user and places it on the
shoulders of the supplier and the
supplier has to uh charge a little extra
money in order to do that that's just an
economic
reality um Point number five uh and I
was really glad to hear my friend Tom
France mention this uh it is a good idea
for the state to consider a variety of
potential approaches to default service
he mentioned a descending clock auction
that's a great idea you might consider
doing that in the context of having all
of the state's default service procured
at the same time in one room someplace
uh that might have some economic
advantages in lower default service
prices Point number six uh
representative Corman mentioned eight
rate cases a uh six straight cases a
year and I I just want to make sure that
there isn't any confusion about
terminology when the Pu reviews default
service filings it isn't conducting a
rate case a rate case is a huge
undertaking we have one pending now with
Liberty Utilities Liberty has about 12
different Witnesses who have submitted
written testimony I have five witnesses
who have submitted testimony for the OCA
the department of energy has six or
seven or eight Witnesses and it takes a
whole year to go through that reviewing
a default service proposal from an
investor on utility is a much more
discreet uh uh undertaking that mostly
involves making sure that there really
was a competitive uh bidding process and
that the price that the utility obtained
really does reflect the market price of
uh of wholesale and Retail electricity
um uh Point number
seven is that the cheapest way of
procuring default service is in fact and
this goes to what representative Summers
was talking about is to do what the New
Hampshire Electric Cooperative does the
New Hampshire Electric Cooperative
doesn't just ladder it has an active and
ongoing portfolio
management uh process that really
resembles what a vertically integrated
utility would have done prior to
restructuring which is to say they
aren't just staggering the expiration
date of their contracts they have at
least one super long-term contract I
mean by super longterm I'm thinking you
know in the order of 25 years with at
least one energy facility and they do
make some spot purchases and they have
other contracts in their portfolio of
varying lengths so the question becomes
why don't we ask our investor-owned
utilities to do that and the answer is
that they don't really have an incentive
to do it as well as the cooperative does
the Cooperative is owned by its
customers so whatever value is derived
from that method of procuring default
service in uras to the benefits of the
owners of the company but for the
investor on utilities there's no
percentage literally and they're doing a
really awesome aggressive Vigilant job
of acquiring default service because
there's no markup for them when they
acquire default service so I guess my
last point is that although you could
change a lot of the shs to maze in the
bill uh or do what uh uh my friend Mike
lato was suggesting I think the better
course is essentially to let the Public
Utilities Commission handle this uh
because it has told you it intends to do
that even uh the existing law gives the
Pu The Authority already to do
everything that we've been talking about
here today if you enact a bill though
there is a St a Canon of statutory
construction that says that the
legislature doesn't waste its time by
enacting bills that mean nothing so
there's always this presumption that you
intended some change in law and I would
urge you not to change the law really
it's a matter of letting the
restructuring act do its job at a time
when the restructuring act might finally
start yielding some real benefits for
residential utility customers thanks to
this incredible experiment we're
embarking on called Community power
aggregation I hope you realize that the
community power aggregation programs
particularly the community power
Coalition of New Hampshire is on its way
to becoming the biggest load serving
entity in the state that's going to have
a big effect on retail electricity in
New Hampshire and I think we need to see
what that effect is I'm hoping it's good
but I'm not guaranteeing it but we are
in the midst of that big experiment
which makes this not the best time to
legislate I think that's everything I
have to say by way of of points thank
you for the opportunity to testify I'd
be happy to sit here and answer
questions for as long as representative
o is willing to let
me well thank you I do have a couple of
quick questions for you the first one is
don't Community aggregation or
aggregators like the community power
Coalition and competitive suppliers
aren't they also subject to risk
premiums yes absolutely I mean anytime
you uh opt for Price certainty the
counterparty to those contracts is
taking on is charging you a risk premium
so that's certainly true of the
community power Coalition it's true of
the Electric Co-op it's true to the
utilities it's true to the competitive
suppliers so is a risk premium the
culprit here or
not ye well
yes uh and and what we see now is a uh
calming down of the uh electricity
market so that default Energy Service
prices have come down to earth so when
you're looking at a price like 8.1 cents
per kilowatt hour which is the new rate
for the community power Coalition or 8.3
cents which is eversource's new rate I
mean there's a risk premium embedded in
that rate that's still higher than the
you know spot price that's probably
prevailing right this minute at ISO New
England but again it's because
residential customers in particular and
I think a lot of commercial customers as
well want price stability so those two
rates are in place for a six-month
period so maybe what you're saying is
that rates contain wholesale supplier
rates contain a risk premium but
sometimes they also contain a panic
premium yes that is true and I think
that is a big explan or a major
explanation of what we've seen in the
last two
question the reason this bill is is
before us and the reason we're here
discussing it is because we have
constituents coming to us when we have
these price spikes saying what the heck
are you guys going to do about the cost
of our
electricity so how do you suggest that
we respond to our constituents when they
start flooding our email inboxes and our
telephone voicemail boxes with
complaints about the cost of energy well
I I I would think the first thing you
would tell them is look at where the
price of default Energy service is now
relative to where it was two years ago
if you want as a political matter you
can take credit for it uh but I would
say uh that you can also refer them to
the Pu because you heard Mr spidel tell
you in effect that the Pu is on the case
and I I go to all the hearings they are
on the case they are actively engaged uh
chairman goldner is I think pretty
obsessed with making some pretty big
changes with the way that default
service is procured I I'm going to try
to convince him to be pretty careful
about that but he seems pretty
determined so you can refer your
constituents to you can refer them to me
because I never leave any query
unanswered especially one that's
referred from legislators so I I hope
those are that's helpful I mean I but I
hear you uh chairman Vose I know that
you all get constit calls and it is easy
or it's preferable for you to be able to
say to your constituents well yes we're
doing something we're we're enacting
house bills
1617 uh but I would urge you to be
careful and consider not doing that
nonetheless okay I'll take your advice
and congratulate my fellow legislators
on lowering the price of energy over the
last six months yes indeed
congratulations to all of you all right
further questions for Mr
cre
seeing none it looks like you've done a
fabulous job as you usually do covering
all the points you wanted to make and so
I thank you for your testimony thank you
very
much and since I have no more pink cards
on this bill I'm going to close the
1617 and that will take us to House Bill
1697 and so I'm going to open that
public hearing and before I call on the
Bill's Prime sponsor I'm going to lay
out some ground rules for this public
hearing I have
17 pink cards 17 people who would like
to
speak looks like another one is winding
its way in my direction so 18 pink cards
uh of people who would like to speak or
19 so given the fact that it is now
10:20 the likelihood of us getting
through all 19 of these pink cards today
is virtually nil so I want to alert you
all to the possibility in fact the very
real probability that this public
hearing will be
recessed and will be resumed at a future
date so you may not get a chance
to testify on this bill today I want you
to be aware of that before we start
now on the other hand there is a
possibility that once the prime sponsor
introduces this bill and explains to us
mistake some of you may decide you don't
want to testify and that would be
wonderful if that proved to be the state
Pro proved to be the
case so let's start and see where this
takes
us I will say that I'm going to cut this
off at about
11:15 and uh we have other matters that
we have to deal with today so we're not
going to go beyond
11:15 so with that I'd like to call Arie
Davis representative Arnold Davis to
introduce House Bill 1697 suspending New
Hampshire's participation in emissions
reduction credit programs for a period
of two
years and representative Davis will
explain to us why that's not really what
he wanted to do okay go ahead thank you
good morning and thank you Mr chairman
members of the committee for the record
my name is annal Davis I'm state
representative from milin Coos District
2 and I'm here today to introduce to you
house bill
1697 and there was a misunderstanding as
the chairman said between OS and myself
the original Bill did not accomplish
what I had intended it to do
I worked with the Attorney General's
office on the language and would like to
attach a draft of the amendment to this
bill and offer it to you today for your
consideration and if I may uh Mr
chairman I'd like to read the
amendment please
do suspension of sale of the of carbon
credits the department of cultural and
natural resources shall suspend the sale
of carbin credits and offsets from The
Woodlands of New Hampshire for two years
from the effective date of this act in
order for the general court to develop a
plan to properly regulate such
sales such
suspension shall not stop purchasing of
carbon credits and offsets in the state
of New Hampshire and shall not affect
the participation in any of the other
emissions trading programs under RSA
125j
any any person requiring carbon credits
and offsets to become carbon neutral or
to meet emission requirements May
purchase such credits and offsets from
other
sources from any
source that is not New Hampshire
Woodlands if the ACT is deemed
unconstitutional that any person who has
entered into the a contract to purchase
sell or trade carbon credits or
offsets that was affected by the
suspension of the sale of carbon credits
and offsets may still be liable for any
rules or taxes pertaining to such
contract this act shall take effect upon
passage so that is basically the
amendment which is the
bill
um I believe this is a vital piece of
legislation one that is dire to to our
state into our way of life this bill is
truly a bipartisan effort as it has the
support of all seven delegation members
in Coos County and all three County
Commissioners I will keep my
introduction brief as you will be
hearing from experts in their respective
Fields who know much more about their
trades than I do and I do not want to be
redundant now let me be clear that we
are not opposed to the Commerce of cbon
credits and offsets as a to the
Woodlands of New Hampshire the purpose
of this bill is to Simply give the state
of New Hampshire a brief pause so that
we can properly regulate these sales we
understand that property owners have
rights and we are not looking to
infringe upon them our intent is to find
a balance where cin credits and offsets
may be sold without harming the timber
indust timber industry loggers truckers
Sawmills and everyone else that this
trickles down to to without harming the
timber tax benefits derived from our
towns without the loss of countless jobs
and at the same time keeping our forests
properly managed and keeping the land
open to recreation in short we are
looking for best management practices
that will benefit both the land owners
in the state of New Hampshire and I
would like to thank you for your time
and
consideration thank you representative
for introducing this
legislation just for
clarity I want to ask you is it your
position that we should
consider
legislation that does nothing to the
regional greenhouse
gas um initiative yes I Reggie would not
be affected by this bill Reggie would
not be affected by this bill at all
that's correct okay and it was never
your intention to suspend reie Reggie
for two years no it was not okay so I
just want everybody who plans to testify
on this bill to understand that this
bill is not about
Reggie this bill is about something
completely different representative
question representative Harrington has a
question sorry I saw a hand waving over
there thank you Mr chairman I please
apologize to representative McGee for
thinking she looked like
me um my question is this you do you
mention uh private land there so it see
I just want to make sure I get the
intent of the bill it seems as what
you're saying is it's going to be a a
two-year moratorium so if I'm a private
land owner and I was approached by
someone who wanted to buy carbon credits
for my forested land I'm assuming that
would mean if I signed that contract I
couldn't cut down the wood so with this
bill as amend Ed in effect say no one
including private land owners can enter
into these contracts and hence prevent
them from cutting the wood down of
course they could still not cut the wood
down but this would say you can't enter
in a contract that mandates that the
wood not be cut is that correct that's
correct all right thank
you additional questions representative
muns has a question thank you
representative uh for uh clarifying the
intent of the bill um I'm I'm a
flatlander I live down on the Sea Coast
um what what uh precipitated this what
why why the need for this bill what what
what's going on that we don't know about
well private private companies are
buying
property and instead of harvesting
Timber they are selling carbon offsets
so where I live the tax base is is
heavily based around around Timber tax
it it's uh creating a loss of jobs it's
creating loss of Timber tax to the
towns um I would like to make sure that
the the land stays open for
recreation and Hunting Fishing
snowmobiling
OHV um and it's we're not trying to stop
it we are just trying to let selling
carbon credits and offsets
coexist with harvesting Timber we're
we're trying to not do away and harm the
timber
industry uh and that's that's where
we're at we're trying to find a a middle
together representative Wendy Thomas has
a question thank you Mr chair um
actually representative Ms um asked the
question that I had which was what
precipitated this um request for a bill
um in the bill you you talk about uh a
period of two years how did you come up
with two years what does that mean
we need a little bit of time to to look
into this and see where if if you put
land into current use you need to put it
into a registry and so we would like to
have some sort of registry where if you
intent to uh sell carbon offsets it
would there would be a registry right
now nobody knows who's who's doing what
uh maybe some sort of of
uh Timber tax if we you say for for the
loss of the Timber tax when you if you
harvest Timber I if I was going to
harvest Timber I would have to fill out
an intent to cut and then I would pay a
10% Timber tax which goes to the towns
so selling
offsets you're you're making commer with
that same Timber even though you're not
cutting it the town's losing their money
which they heavily depend on in Coos
County and and I don't know about the
rest of the state but I would imagine so
uh so we'll looking to protect that
we're looking to protect the logging
industry if you're a second third
generation logger in Pittsburgh New
Hampshire and you have uh it's very
expensive for that equipment if
you go out of business because there's a
lack of work those jobs aren't coming
back nobody's going to go from
Whitefield to Lancaster up to Pittsburgh
to cut low grade Timber it's just not
industry followup
thank you um you mentioned um a registry
you mentioned study um do you see the
county setting up a committee to to look
into this alongside independent but
alongside of this legislation yes I I
just don't want it to go to interterm
study because that's a polite way to
kill something uh I I think we could
form a committee that could look into
this very quickly and working with Dr
working with uh excuse me I'm meant a
committee outside of the the legislature
like a county committee yeah I I I think
you're
right all right before we uh move along
I want to clarify a situation I'm going
to call on you for but for the moment I
want to
clarify
that the draft amendment that
representative Davis read to us during
his testimony is quite different from
what the original Bill text
was there is possibly a question about
the
gerain of that Amendment
text but I have
decided not to waste the time of
everybody who showed up here this
morning by saying that we can't discuss
that Amendment text because that is what
we will go forward with we won't go go
forward with the original Bill
text so I want everybody to understand
that even though I haven't spoken to the
speaker about it yet there is a
possibility that this amendment is non-
gerine and if it is then we're going to
have to have another public hearing on
that
Amendment but in the interest of saving
time for people who have traveled here
this morning I'm going to continue with
our questioning and our
testimony on the idea of the proposed
draft amendment that representative
Davis has suggested to us just so we can
get a sense of what it really is all
about and what its implications might be
if we decide to move forward with it
with that I'll call on res uh
representative McGee for a question
thank you Mr chairman um and thank you
for taking my question since I've had
conversations representative with
yourself and others in the North Country
um and also um I spoke with the
president of the New Hampshire Society
for the protection of forests about this
bill um I I wondered if you it seems
like people are curious how the bill
came about and in your
explanation um you didn't really mention
the change that's happened with this
purchase in other words the way the land
was being maintained the sustainable
harvesting um is really one of the main
things that's changed right so it's not
it's not just the timber tax but it's
also um the guarantee of the owners of
the land that it will be sustainably
harvested and forested for the
protection of the land and we I know we
had that discussion so I'm just
wondering if you could say a little more
about what's changed um which really
prompted this well it's not just one
piece of
sorry uh it's not just one piece of land
we're talking about if uh one parcel was
purchased in Pittsburgh and that has a
significant effect on on our County uh
other parles that will follow I'm just
trying to get ahead of the curve here
and and would I mean it's very early and
into okay seeing no other questions for
representative Davis I want to move
along here we have a lot of people who
would like to say something about this
situation Mr chairman yes Joe Kenny the
executive counselor was supposed to
speak here this morning he was here for
9:30 he the other Bill ran over he left
testimony can I if uh bring them up to
you I was about to call on counselor
Kenny well I didn't realize he left
he'll be back if he can he said if if
this is still going on
when okay I'll put his card on the
bottom of the pile and if he makes it
back we'll call on him next is um Robert
County
okay thank you Mr chairman and thank you
uh members of the committee uh my name
is Robert Tiel I was a representative
for 22 years so and I know what it's
like being shairing of a committee so I
will be very very brief um the uh the
bill has had a a tremendous impact in
the North Country you mentioned how has
started about but in Pittsburgh when uh
loose Source purchased the land they
stopped harvesting of the Timber which
resulted in the mile and Lumber Company
being closed for three weeks because it
couldn't get uh lumber at all there's an
important economic aspect to this bill
municipalities look forward to
recreational use of land this may have a
negative impact on them but more
importantly if a municipality can't
can't purchase land for Workforce
housing that will not benefit anybody at
all and for Progress um we've talked
about the timber or the forested lands
what is not mentioned in this bill in in
the future not only will forested lands
be affected but any agricultural land
for carbon
credits thank you I'll be brief okay we
appreciate revity believe me uh any
questions for The Honorable
representative yes um representative
Harrington thank you and thank you for
taking my question um my first reaction
to this is that you're going to put a
moratorium on people have that own their
own property saying I want to enter into
a contract that's legal and it's going
to say I don't cut down wood on my
property well it's my property I should
have the right to make that decision
shouldn't I I mean where are we going to
go next when we can tell people you
can't do this with your property because
we want you to cut wood we're going to
force people to cut wood on their
property is that the next
step I think there's a misunderstanding
representative uh if uh individuals work
you know enter into contract with uh an
entity for carbon credits um I'm I'm
sure they can negotiate what the terms
would be um some municipalities
California has gone way way way out on a
limb with this not allowing U harvesting
of Timbers and and whatnot so I I think
it's a it would
benefit U both entities the land owner
and whoever wants to you purchase for uh
carbon credits to come with some type of
agreement which I feel is reasonable
moving
forward follow
up followup okay but so I'm getting
clear so what the bill says we don't
have in front of us but just want to
make it clear what this bill have passed
it would say for 2 years no one is
allowed to sign a contract for carbon
credits hence they couldn't sign a
contract to sell someone we're not going
to cut down a wood on my property no
that's not the case of theill would you
explain what it is then because maybe
I'm misunderstanding it well I think
representative Davis could do a better
job of that or um Mike wette
representative Mike bant um the there's
no moror on S selling or purchasing land
it's just a moratorium on how carbon
credits are to be used in the future uh
what is u a problem with the whole thing
and speaking with the Dr is uh how are
you going to do uh when it comes to um
uh taxing carbon credits that's an
entirely different ball of
wax Mr chairman could I make a
suggestion here since we don't have the
bill in front of us and since there
seems to be quite a bit confusion about
it exactly does and does not do I would
suggest until we get a copy of the bill
so we can look at it and make some um
intelligent questions that we suspend
the hearing because without the copy of
the bill we just be getting bounced
around all over the place that is a
reasonable request and I have just
learned uh from a visit with the house
clerk that because this bill affects the
same section of law as the
original originally fed bill it is
Germain therefore I'm going to ask
representative Davis to pass out copies
of his proposed amendment so that we can
discussing does that does that excuse me
does that uh satisfy your your concern
representative Harrington thank you it
does okay please go ahead and answer the
question well I was waiting for support
from uh you know re pres of Davis and
also Mike wette representative wet are
more in tune to what's going on
regarding this bill because they've been
working on it for a number of weeks um
you know I stepped in as a kind of
commissioner because we totally
understand what the problem would be
facing uh the timber industry which is a
really important uh the logging industry
is extremely important in the North
country has it would have a negative
impact if uh contracts are issued where
timber who do we have uh
here joining me is uh representative
Mike wette oh this is representative
wette yes nice to see you again sir I'm
co-sponsor of the bill I'm sorry no
thank you very much and U I have a card
from you uh I was going to call on you
but go ahead since you're there well I
just come up to support Mr T um and to
answer the question we're not trying to
stop uh uh uh wood cutting or carbon
sales uh as if this passes through and
uh we create the legislation um what
we're saying is if there's some fees or
something is going to be due um they'll
be retroactive to where we are but we're
anything okay additional questions
representative McGee and this is based
on the language in the bill um I I
understand the idea of um allowing sales
to go forward but uh but people will not
have the certainty of understanding you
know where you're going to land right so
it may actually affect the market anyway
right people may not want to enter into
a deal where they don't know the outcome
so um it sounds like what you're saying
is you want to impose um a moratorium in
order to figure out a solution but you
don't know what the collateral impacts
of that's going to be on the economy for
for large tracks of Woodland own owners
you know for land
owners that's that is correct um and and
it's um we've been working on this for a
number of months many months and it is a
very complex Hydra of of questions and
an answers and trying at the same time
to protect everybody's property rights
and uh protect our way of life so um
this moratorium is just to give us time
to create something that is uh
acceptable and workable to protect the
Hampshire yes please do a
followup because I'm than I'm confused
about some of this language um I I I am
curious in listening to the testimony
whether
uh that solution could be worked on
bill we don't I think part of
the issue is that we want to make sure
that we're protecting all property long
term and when we talk about people's
properties you know uh we want to
protect the guy that's got 40
acres um the Pittsburgh Property that
was mentioned it's a little different
because there's easements on the
property but just to be clear that's 225
square miles on one piece of property
that's had a great effect on not only
North Country but the state of New
Hampshire um there's another piece in
Colombia it's 8,000 Acres I mean that's
many miles square miles of
property um so we're just trying to get
ahead of the curve slow things down make
a a workable solution to protect the
again the state of New
Hampshire follow up to that if I'm
allowed go ahead would be um what effect
you think this bill will have in
assisting you with any negotiation or
determination um because if the bill
passes then the people that you'll be
talking to the effed people may have
more incentive to come to the table and
participate in a process to try and
figure out Solution that's really the
only thing I can see that would be
enabled by a change like
this and that is true but the there's a
lot of uh facets to this uh between uh
Timber values uh Recreation and a lot of
it is is way of life that we have in in
New Hampshire and I think that if you a
little patient and hear some of the
other uh people testify it's going to
expound on on your
question
so representative Harrington has a
question now that I have the bill in
front of me I'm more confused than ever
um it says the department of cultural
and natural resources shall suspend the
sale of carbon credits and offsets from
The Woodlands of New Hampshire for two
years then it goes on to say such
suspension shall not stop the purchase
of carbon credits and offsets in the
state of New Hampshire and then it goes
on to say offsets
p May purchase credits and offsets from
any source that is not in New Hampshire
Woodland so what is it is there a
two-year suspension of let me put it
this way I own land I want to someone
approaches me they say I want to sign a
contract with you for carbon credits
because I have a factory in Oklahoma
that produces carbon dioxide and I want
to go carbon neutral so I'm going to
sign a contract with you for 10 years
and I will pay you not to cut down any
wood on your property is that contract
let's say for two years because we get
the two years is that contract barred by
this two-year suspension of the sale of
offsets in my opinion no so what is bar
then excuse me um what we're going to
say is if you sell those carbon credits
and the legislation comes up that
there's some uh could be a time limit on
the amount time for the lease on the
carbon credits or could be a uh some
kind of a fee to make the town's
wholesale for the loss of Timber tax
you'll be responsible for that down the
road
followup follow up that sounds like a
retroactive law which is
unconstitutional you can't tell someone
they can enter in a contract today and
it's legal and then two years from now
say oops we changed the law no
retroactively we're going to find
you I think this needs a lot more work
it's very very confusing it does I I
don't disagree but it takes time and be
assured uh everything that we've done
has gone through the Attorney General's
office it's nothing that we've taken off
the cuff and we're very conscientious to
make sure everything we do is legal and
and
constitutional representative Harrington
turn off your mic please sorry okay uh
representative rolds has a question
thank you Mr chairman and um thank you
I'd like to thank my colleague
representative Harrington for his effort
to clarify because I'm kind of in the
same boat now just having having the
text of the bill in front of me I just
term from The Woodlands of New
Hampshire by and you would you would
have
the the
state the department of cultural and
natural resources suspect the sale of
carbon credits and offsets from The
Woodlands of New Hampshire do you mean
the woodlands do you mean Parcels of
Woodland owned by the state of New
Hampshire or do you mean all Woodlands
all Parcels public and
private it would it would be all and
because I think thanks
that's okay um Miss okay I have a a
statement I'd like to read Mr chairman
if we have a second okay make it quick
please okay uh let me start out by
saying that I support land owners rights
to sell carbon credits uh however carbon
credits derived from the timber could
have a devastating effect on the state's
economy and our traditional way of
life when our ancestors settled in the
1600s over 90% of the land in the state
of New Hampshire was forested by the
mid- 1800s it was down to less than 40%
of our land was forested with the
majority being north of the White
Mountains today the state of New
Hampshire is 82% forested which is only
second to the state of
Maine uh the business of selling carbon
is that we're larger trees the larger
tree go the more carbon there is to sell
and my topic today is is how it affects
the sports and and
Recreation and you might ask what has to
do with
sportsmen New Hampshire is a unique in
that hunters and fishermen have free
range to hunt and fish unencumbered all
over the state on primarily privately
owned land that is generously made open
to the
public but the sale of Timberlands for
carbon credits could change
that uh young growing forests provide
food and habitat for most of our
Wildlife older mature forests contain
less feed less
animals with there being approximately
50,000 licensed Hunters and over 170,000
licensed fishermen in New Hampshire the
depletion of the state's wildli Wild
game would also affect over 2 billion
dollars uh that hunting and fishing
industries contribute to the state's
economy
annually every year when winter comes
about 45,000 snowmobiles are registered
across the state to ride New Hampshire's
7,000 miles of open Trails according to
an economic impact study made by the
University of New Hampshire the a
average economic impact of snow buers in
state is estimated at $548 million
annually then once the snow has melted
uh New Hampshire opens over a th000
miles of ohrv trails to approximately
41,000 ohvs wheel Vehicles contributing
an additional $465 million annually to
the state's
economy over 80% of the state's Trails
reside on private property over
80%
and what has that got to do with carbon
credits well unfortunately many of the
companies purchasing the land for
benefits of selling carbon credits have
an ESG policy that conflicts with the
allowance of motorized
Sports other areas across the country
have already felt the impact of
previously available lands haven't been
shut down to the public for the use of
motorized Sports these potential
closures could eliminate an industry
that contributes nearly one billion
dollars to New Hampshire's
economy we need legislation to encourage
carbon sales but we also need to create
incentives for these landowners to
professionally manage their forest and
keep their land open for recreation and
traditional
traditional uses to our way of life it's
important that we pass this bill to give
us the necessary time to create
legislation that will protect our land
owners our tourists and the economic
contributions of our state's outdoor
recreation Industries thank you so did I
understand you to say that
this carbon purchase carbon credit
purchase
program is more is about more than just
Timber harvesting it's also about
Recreation and the use of land Beyond
Timber harvesting absolutely we we've
seen other uh areas across the country
uh being shut down um for uh carbon
sales and environmental uh reasons um
and like I said it's billions of dollars
the state of New
Hampshire
okay representative muns has a question
I'd remind the members we have quite a
few more people would like to testify
thank you Mr chair and thank you for um
enlightening us on this issue um I I I
was interested I found it interesting
that in your in your
statement you you did not mention the
timber tax uh how much of a motivator is
legislation it's like ific um and and
it's not just the timber tax but it's
the proper management of our forests uh
to we need the timber low grade Timber
uh in their North Country we need high-
grade timber for furniture Lumber um we
Timber tax is is is also a good thing
but we need to properly manage our
forest for our wildlife habitat also
that's why I mean it's so many varied
areas uh representative Davis myself and
the rest of the Coos County delegation
um very much P bipartisan are working on
this together um and when we were going
to sit down here today try not to be
redundant um uh representative Davis
asked me if I would look at the
recreational part of it which I've been
involved with for many decades and so
this is my take on the uh recreational
part of the uh
legislation upcoming legislation I
should
say okay okay representative L liwicki
has a question uh thank you Mr chairman
thank you for taking my question uh
presumably presumably this land is in
current use would the restrictions on it
um by the by an owner a new owner affect
that current use
status it depends on what their current
current uh uh use is meaning if they're
open to motorized Recreation now and
they close it then their current use
but we we we are very aware the success
of current use of State of New Hampshire
and um are not interested in making any
changes on the current use policies at
this
time representative Corman has a
question thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question I'm wondering if
you can help me read this amendment uh
because I'm I'm having a little trouble
parsing it I think our chairman is also
having a little trouble parsing it I
think the rest of the committee is too
so let me give you an interpretation of
how I'm reading this and you tell me if
I'm off the mark please if you if I'm
sorry excuse me if you don't mind I'm
gonna have representative Davis is the
one that's worked on this part of it and
I'm gonna have him up so we make sure
answers are accurate that that's great I
I just want to make sure I understand it
um so if C can we bring representative
Davis back to to help us with this it's
fine with me okay if one of the other
great thank you yes so the the first
sentence says the department of cultural
and natural resources shall suspend the
sale of carbon credits and offsets from
The Woodlands of New Hampshire for two
years from the effective date of this
act
Etc the second sentence says such
suspension shall not stop the purchasing
of carbon credits and offsets in the
state of New Hampshire Etc so am I
correct in interpreting it that the
first sentence says this state agency
will no longer sell carbon credits and
offsets for two years but the second
sentence says that Private Sales may
occur what what the intention of this is
the Department of cultural and natural
resources shall suspend the sale of
carbon credits and offsets in the wood
from The Woodlands of New Hampshire for
two years from the effective date of
this order so what that means is
suspending the sale of carbon carbon
credits and offsets from timber in New
Hampshire uh for two years the the
reason is to allow the general court to
develop a plan to regulate these sales
right now they are unregulated there no
we have no idea who's selling them uh
because they're sold generally to
California I don't know if they pay a
business profit tax to New Hampshire I
New Hampshire gets zero out of this deal
except for a loss of jobs uh such
suspension shall not stop the purchasing
of carbon credits and offsets in the
state of New Hampshire well there's
there's other programs other than the
Timberlands there's uh many other
programs that do not deal with with
Timber so those can still be purchased
we're not we're not trying to stop that
and this shall not affect any other
emissions programs under RSA 125o and
RSA 125j so it does not affect Reggie
does not affect any other plan or
program out there uh so if you if you
have a company and you're looking to
purchase uh Caron credit and offsets as
long as they don't come from the timber
of New
Hampshire buy them that
way yes yes follow up thank you okay so
thank you for that clarification uh my
my proposed interpretation was erroneous
and I'm glad to know that so let me just
make sure again that I understand so the
first sentence is saying that the sale
of carbon credits and offsets from just
from The Woodlands of New Hampshire is
being suspended yes
all private sales of such credits are
suspended for two years is that correct
not not cutting Timber Just just the
credits just the credits yeah and then
the second sentence where it says such
suspension shall not stop the purchasing
of carbon credits and offsets what what
it's really saying is for anything other
than Woodlands yes okay it might help if
that was actually included in that
second this was filed late I wasn't able
to a redraft at
OS uh so I I'm willing to work on an
amendment with the committee if that
good thank
you all right so let's um let's suspend
any kind
of critique of the language of the bill
to make sure that before we go further
down into those weeds we understand the
concept and to that end I'm going to ask
ask you two gentlemen to step
aside because this bill will affect a
particular piece of property in the
North
Country more than any other a property
called Aurora sustainable
lands and so I would like to hear from
Blake stamell who represents Aurora
sustainable lands to hear what he has to
say about the approach of this proposed
legislation
Mr
stanel thank you Mr chairman um and
committee members appreciate the
opportunity to be here and uh again my
name's Blake stansil I'm the president
of Aurora sustainable
lands um we are the owner of the
Connecticut Lakes Forest that's up in
Pittsburgh Stewartstown and Clarksville
and I think this bill is directly
targeted at us we um we didn't come
prepared with written statements about
the amendment because we've just seen it
but I think I can address everything
that's been brought up here by giving
you a feel for uh what our company's all
about and the plans we have for managing
this forest
and I think it's worth saying right up
front um we
we pay taxes in New Hampshire we pay
business tax we pay property tax we pay
Timber Severance tax um we there's a
road sharing agreement where we we pay
uh for a component of that so that's one
item that I'll talk some more about and
then secondly from a recreational
standpoint the carbon program that we
have is absolutely compatible with
recreational use and does not have an
impact
uh on the recreational side and then the
the logging piece which is probably of
most interest uh to many in the North
Country I'd love to speak to that as
well so uh hope to be able to hit on all
of those uh with some of my prepared
comments um first maybe just a few facts
about the property
itself um it's the largest privately
held forest in the state that's open to
public rec
creation um the property has been
privately held under this working Forest
conservation easement since
2003 um the easement provides
for uh continued Public Access in
perpetuity uh it provides for um the
property to be managed as a working
Forest so generating Forest Products for
the manufacturing facility ities
throughout the region um the property
has had a carbon project on it since
2013 so the the carbon project has been
around for uh for quite some time um our
company manages 1.65 million Acres
throughout the United States with a
primary purpose of removing and storing
carbon from the
atmosphere um this property is very
similar to a lot of properties we manage
in other locations it's 146,000 Acres so
clearly a big piece of property what's
unique about it is it does have a
working Forest conservation easement on
it we have other assets that also uh
have easements but one thing I would say
is from the perspective of
Regulation this asset is probably one of
the most regulated in our portfolio
already um there's a large amount of
interaction between our forestry staff
and the division of forests and
lands um we interact directly with the
local community uh there regular
meetings around Recreation and tourism
so from from that perspective absolutely
see no reason to add
regulation uh around what we're
discussing
today um and and then on the the timber
side uh just a few things to to comment
on because we we recognize the impact to
the North country as it relates to to
harvesting Timber we're going to
absolutely continue to harvest as a
matter of fact uh harvesting is ongoing
on the property right now there's
logging crews out on the property as of
yesterday I spoke to some of our
Foresters um and while the overall
volume of Timber it will will be reduced
and has been reduced the type of Timber
harvesting that we're doing is more
labor intensive um we we're focusing
more on what's an individual tree
selection we're focusing more on data
collection on the front end to make sure
we understand what we're
harvesting um and so at the end of the
day we believe that over time the type
of harvesting we're doing will increase
the stocking of temp and carbon on the
property and it also enhance the growth
of the forest um we we completely
recognize that a healthy Forest is a
managed forest and a managed Forest
means there's logging occurring and and
we intend to continue to do that um I
think the the process that we're
implementing is more labor intensive on
a Timber sale by Timber sale basis so we
anticipate you know needing more
Foresters more surveyors more
Specialists on the ground and so I think
long term it's a positive for the
property itself um we understand that
reduced logging volume has a specific
impact in terms of Timber tax and the
majority of the severance tax we pay
goes to to the town of Pittsburgh uh we
have an agreement in principle
with the town to um make up the
shortfall in Timber tax
revenue that will be generated in the
current fiscal year relative to what's
been generated on average historically
so we're we're communicating regularly
with the Town Council and working on
that for the for the current year um May
I interrupt you right there yeah you
said that you've been managing maning
this property since
2013 presumably you've been cutting wood
since
2013 has has there been a recent
reduction in in the amount of wood
you're taking from the property there
has been yes the the property's been
managed under the carbon project since
2013 um the the company that owns it now
became the owner at the end of 2022
through a merger with the forest Land
Group and I know the names are probably
getting confusing here but I was the
president of the forest Land Group so I
had a lot of history with the property
if you look at the Harvest volumes over
time the Harvest volume before the
easement was put in place of
2003 um
was a good bit higher than what you saw
the decade after the easement went in
place and since that time there's been a
continual decline in the amount of
property thank you sorry to interrupt
you continue no problem uh I I'll
conclude with just a few quick comments
I mean I want to say with the the
strongest possible conviction that we
recognize our responsibility as stewards
of this remarkable natural resource and
we look forward to continuing to work
with the local community the state
legislature and public officials to uh
ensure the protection of the resource
for generations to come H happy to
provide additional comments or answer
questions representative McGee has a
question thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question um so I took
some notes on what you said and I
understand the properties you know been
used for and continues to be used for
and managed for carbon
sequestration um but it it it sounds
from your description as though many of
the concerns that we heard in the in the
North Country legislators who came
before us are already being either
worked on or have been solved so um can
you speak to you said um that there's
been a decline I had heard somewhere
that the decline in the in the forestry
was by about 50% so I don't know can you
speak to that can you put a number to
how much it's dropped yeah that's
correct it it's roughly 50% and and it
it will vary from year to year based on
an approved annual operating plan that
uh gets approved by Forest and lands of
New Hampshire so but but our long-term
expectation when I say long-term over
the next 5 to 10 years is roughly a 50%
reduction and followup followup and the
last note that I made that I wanted to
ask you about was you mentioned um that
you're working with the town or local
folks to make up the shortfall in the
temp tax so I'm curious about that as
well um how is that ongoing how how do
these folks not how are they not aware
that that's being done because it sounds
like you're doing all the right things
but I'd like to get you know that on the
record too if we could yeah the the
specific process that's occurring there
is uh our Forester who's in charge of
the property is uh attending the Town
Council meetings and he he's an active
dialogue and has communicated
what we're willing to do and so they're
working through formalizing that that
plan formalizing addressing the
shortfall in the timber tax is what
we're saying sorry for formalizing
making up the gap between what was paid
historically in Timber tax and what will
be paid in the current fiscal year
recognizing reduced Harvest
yeah representative Kaplan has a
question and please Tony speak as close
to the mic as you
thank you Mr chair I'll try to make
myself Hur I just had a question about
the original easement that the property
was under is that still in place in the
sustainable harvesting of Timber does
that accommodate the carbon project that
is currently there yes we we yes it does
easement still in place the carbon
project doesn't impact the easement
we're we're still living by the absolute
letter and spirit of the of the
easement the easement you refer to is
one that was brokered by Jud Greg and
Jean Shaheen back in 2002 is that
correct yes sir thank you uh
representative Ms has a question thank
you Mr chair and um thank you for taking
my question can you uh talk just a
little bit about how the carbon
credits
um uh or what role the carbon credits
have in your business model and and and
kind and quite frankly what this what
the impact of a two-year suspension
would be on your business
yeah um the it it would have an impact
on us for sure and and uh it's our
primary business to manage the forest
that we manage and own to generate
carbon credits um we have this uh
optimization approach where we're
generating revenue from multiple sources
Timber harvesting carbon credits leasing
land selling land so it's a it's a
for-profit business where we're making
decisions as a private land owner using
the tools that are available to us um
but certainly the focus is on carbon
credit
generation followup followup so what it
would a two-year suspension have any
impact on you know your your your
harvesting
operations employment
Etc so the a 2-year moratorium would
just have an impact on the the carbon
credits were selling we we wouldn't
change our management strategy in terms
of what we're doing in the in the forest
and around harvesting that that would
continue but it it would it would be a
big hit to
revenue if we couldn't sell carbon
credits thank
you okay I uh said earlier that I was
going to cut this
short at
11:15 and we have reached that mile
Stone so at this point in time I am
going to recess this public hearing we
will reconvene at a time and date to be
determined it will be published in the
house calendar and I apologize to all of
you for forcing you to come back to do
this uh at a different time but I was
unaware at the time I scheduled this
hearing at what a
complicated and convoluted problem that
this particular bill has
introduced and I think it needs thorough
explanation from all the different
stakeholders many of whom have already
expressed a desire to
speak so in order order to accommodate
all those stakeholders I think we have
to suspend today and come back and do
this another time I think I'll schedule
it for two hours or maybe three uh when
we resume but we're going to have to cut
it short for today I think we the
relatively or a relative understanding
of what the issues are
and that will enable us to ask more
pertinent questions when we bring you
all back uh in a few
um a few days or a few weeks whatever
whatever the case Mr Mr chairman
question yes representative bus you have
a question um I I completely agree with
your your approach the only question I
guess I would ask is there anybody that
has traveled from out of state that
wanted to testify today that we might
want to try to
accommodate well unfortunately we we
just can't accommodate that I I I would
like I said I apologize to anybody who
traveled from out of state or any place
else um that that we have to cut this
short but we just have no choice I'll
accept the responsibility for making the
mistake of not scheduling a long enough
public hearing for this complicated
question but I didn't realize that it
was this complicated so um that's my
only defense otherwise I do take
responsibility and I'd apologize for the
mistake but uh at this time uh I'm going
to
uh recess this public hearing to a time
in date certain which will be published
in the house
calendar
simultaneously I'm going to open a work
session for the committee on several
yesterday well hang on I'm not done I've
opened the full committee uh work
session because it is scheduled in the
house
calendar I am going to call an immediate
break
of that full committee work session
afternoon I'm further going to call that
there will be a republican caucus in
this
room immediately so I ask everybody in
the room who is not a member of the
Republican caucus of the st& to exit the
room as quickly as you can thank you
want me see if I
get
please clear the room please for a
republican
caucus you
you
St
so
for
right
oh
what
okay everybody good afternoon welcome to
the afternoon session session of science
technology and energy for January 9th
2024 this afternoon we have a a full
committee work session that we're going
to be resuming we started that full
committee work session
before lunch at about 11:15 or
11:20 we took a break at that time and
now we are resuming that work session
and we're going to look at uh the five
bills that we
we had public hearings on
yesterday and then at 2:00 we're going
to open an executive session on those
same five
bills so we'll start our work session by
discussing House Bill
and I'm passing out to the commit
members of the committee an amendment
that representative Thomas Doug Thomas
that is has filed
to
transform House Bill 1047 from a
legislative study committee into a study
by the Department of Health and use
Services Human Services and the
Affairs we suggest that this is a better
way
to get the data that will be meaningful
to potential future legislation to solve
this problem and so that is why we are
suggesting
this uh this amendment so as soon as you
get a copy of the amendment I would like
everybody to spend a couple of
minutes taking a look at it a couple
extra copies here if anybody
uh would like
them and then we'll have a disc
discussion
about
yep Jim Summers did you put a copy
before they have them okay good okay
does everybody over here have a copy
cren okay I'll give you a couple of
seconds to read through this and then
we'll have a
discussion
it's
okay everybody had a chance to look this
over I'd like to hear some comments from
people representative McGee what do you
think uh thank you Mr chairman I I
actually think it's it's a good idea I
think that um the agencies that are
identified in
here may know more you know they may
know more
off Off the Mark than we do they may you
know they may be starting from a better
point and they also have uh an interest
in doing this and they probably have a
better understanding than the
legislative members would have in terms
of how to get this done so I actually
like the change I think it's
good I know representative Muse who was
the Prime sponsor of the bill was a
little bit skeptical about whether the
Departments the
agencies were
able to be unbiased about collecting
this data but I do think they are the
best individuals to collect the data so
I I think it's a good a good
approach um I'd hear like to hear what
representative Doug Thomas has to say
since he filed the amendment oh I just
wanted to say that uh nothing was
changed as far as the duties go the the
duties remain the same it's just that
the the the impus of who does
the investigation was shifted to a to
State agencies which we think is a
better place for it to be otherwise the
bill basically stays the same except for
the necessary changes that uh obviously
that are not related to being a study
committee
so representative Wendy Thomas as a
co-sponsor of this bill I'm anxious to
hear your thoughts thank you um I
actually uh like this amendment I think
it cuts through the Chase and it it does
what most likely would have been a
recommendation of the committee anyway
so um I'm I'm for this
amendment further comments
representative Corman thank you uh the
only question I have is now that we're
actually directing or now that the
amendment would direct state agencies to
do something would there be a fiscal
note
attached I don't know that fiscal notes
typically get attached to amendments but
um I suppose it could happen if somebody
requested
it yeah so it'll be up to the
um if this bill makes it to the senate
in its current form as amended then it
would be up to the Departments to chime
in at that time and say oh you're going
to have to give us more money and more
staff to do this otherwise we can't do
it so representative cren what do you
have to say I guess that was going to be
my next question was whether we had
contacted either of these departments
and asked as them if they were cool with
this um or if they would need additional
uh resources to to complete such
research we'll find out when it gets to
the
Senate further comments representative
Harrington yeah I just make note on this
that um even though it's not
specifically for this uh with getting
devices to people you know one of the
big reasons I would think that people
didn't have computers to hook up to the
Internet is they don't have internet
access so the New Hampshire has received
over 20 over $200 million as part of the
internet for all and federal funding and
most recently $1 million was given to
Grafton County I believe was last week
so possibly in that money there may be
some thing that be used to look at these
things as well because obviously if you
don't have internet uh you're not going
to have a computer because you get
nothing to connect it to so what
department is in charge of that funding
I'm not sure it's not Dees yeah one at a
time everybody remember no speaking
uh representative Ms has a question or a
comment I U I like this approach a lot
uh in terms of U you know asking
departments to provide a report and um I
appreciate the fact that the language is
as representative Doug Thomas said the
language is is identical to what was in
the original Bill two two two comments
though one of the things and this is the
maybe the more substantive comment what
I took away from some of the testimony
we heard and I think it was part of the
testimony that representative Muse
shared with us is that this is a much
bigger issue than just computer access
it's an issue about the effectiveness of
the of the communication efforts across
the board that are being done and I'm
I'm just wondering whether we want to
acknowledge that and maybe change the
wording a little bit in terms of the
intent so that it doesn't just focus on
on people that don't have computer
access that's that's the one comment and
then the second comment which is more
nitpicky um but um you know we've
identified the Department of Health and
Human Services and Department of
Business and economic Affairs which
probably are the the right two agencies
but maybe include some language that
says you know that encourages them to
reach out to other agencies that they
think may be
impacted that's in
idea representative
rols thank you Mr chairman well I was
largely gonna say I uh appreciate
representative Doug
Thomas's uh effort here and I like it um
but I was going to note that it doesn't
mention the department of energy which I
thought was U the thrust of a lot of uh
while it does say the those two
departments are encouraged to reach out
to others um I thought there was a lot
of I guess in the discussion of this one
and and our colleague representative
grassley's Bill there was a lot of uh
thought about all the weatherization and
those kinds of programs that are
Department of energy focused so maybe we
might mention them and it it doesn't
mention the cap agencies which I thought
have a lot of the might have a lot of
the data here I really realiz that the
it's a catchall that they're encouraged
to reach out to the others but that's
what I noticed any additional
comments representative Corman thank you
I just wanted to um answer
representative Harrington's question
about the funding in Grafton County and
I invite representative bney to correct
me if I'm misremembering but uh as I
recall that funding is entirely for
stringing wires uh to connect the the
county go ahead representative
Harrington yeah yeah I understand that
my point was just that if you don't have
the wire there or the or the fiber optic
you're not going to buy a device that
allows you to get on the internet
because you have no way of doing it that
was my whole point so if we get more
internet access to people then maybe
they solve their own problem they go out
and buy a computer so I think this is
intended to be a like bigger picture but
just just making note of that that's
part of the problem
anyways
okay any other discussion on this
bill seeing none let's move on to the
1230 this is a bill relative
to keep all my paperwork straight here
relative to establishing a committee to
exam examine weatherization ini
initiatives for homes in New
the consensus of my caucus was that this
bill should be it for the very reason
that as the department of energy
testified they have an ongoing
weatherization they call it program
that's over a decade
old uh spins $2 million a year and
Deuces to some recent Federal funding is
going to increase to about five and a
half half million dollar a year over the
next five years New Hampshire saves has
been in existence for over a
decade weatherization is well understood
its benefits are well understood its
costs are fairly well understood we just
can't see any reason
why we need a a committee to study
weatherization initiatives in New
Hampshire so I'd be interested in
hearing other points of view on this on
this
legislation
representative Wendy Thomas thank you um
the way that I see this bill I see it
linking arms with the with the bill that
we just looked at the Communications
bill and you know maybe this bill is
putting the cart before the horse I mean
if we can establish where their
communication leaks or or drops in New
Hampshire um then once that's
established we can figure out how to
so well I remember from yesterday's
public hearing I asked the department of
energy if they could comment on the
$400,000 in yearly funds that are
allocated to the department to
promulgate the benefits of Energy
Efficiency and Mr Roberge at the time
said that he would have to get back to
us on that because he didn't have
details on the program but I would
remind members that that program which
is is not insignificant is designed to
do exactly the kind of communications
Outreach that this bill and the previous
with okay any further comment
representative Corman thank you um I I
actually intend to vote for the bill I
don't love the bill but I intend to vote
for the bill um in large part because I
do work with a local nonprofit in the
Upper Valley and a big part of our focus
is weatherization and I want to promote
that but also the bill uh does contain
uh a degree of measuring and I think
it's good to to be able to measure what
we're
doing okay thank you for your
perspective other
comments representative
ner we have way too many studies as it
is and I don't want to vote to add to
that
list
well it is well known that study
committees particularly in the second
year of a bium are under some extreme
time pressure because they their work
has to be done before the members of the
committee leave office potentially at
the end of um the second year of the
bium that is a that is a
perennial problem with second year study
committees representative Wendy Thomas
yes thank you um just because we're in
the second year of the term doesn't mean
that we shouldn't be doing good work if
for I agree the question is can we do
good work when we're under such
significant time
pressure uh as you well recall
frequently bills that we pass out of the
house and the Senate don't reach the
governor's desk until June
July they can be signed into law and
then the speaker's office has to appoint
members of the study committee it can be
September or October before a study
committee even convenes and I know this
for a fact because I've been on a couple
of study committees that were appointed
in September or October and had
to run like mad to get a report out by
November 1st so no I understand that and
I appreciate it but if we're going to
make a joint decision um and vote
against all study committee
bills then why are we even accepting any
year Well if they're filed you have to
accept them I don't think you can reject
them
so representative n do we know if the
Senate is accepting them I know like um
if we in previous years we've um passed
resolutions and they won't even look at
them the Senate has a very negative
attitude toward study committee bills
and
they did um itl several of the study
committee bills that we passed last year
they did accept a few however so it's
it's not a
uniform um position on the part of the
senate representative n one last comment
and any representative that wants to
learn more about anything they can go to
legislative research and there's a paid
staff who can do the research for you
that's true that's very
true additional
comments seeing none we'll move on to
the next
bill which is House Bill 1289
establishing a commission to study the
replacement of the peer plant in bow
with a clean energy based load generator
and
storage my caucus feels that this is a
well-intentioned build but it is just
not workable simply because a study
commission can't tell a private business
what it can or cannot do with regard to
an energy plant so um that itl would be
our preferred um action on this bill
representative McGee I was just going to
say our my caucus has the exact same
opinion that the bill is well
intentioned but that it isn't workable
so representative Harrington
no need to add anything more oh
okay anybody else have anything to add
on this
one looks like uh we're all in agreement
on this one so hb1 1499 would be next
and this would
establish a
um a committee to study the civilian
clean energy Community resilience and
conservation core
and during the course of the public
hearing on this
bill I asked the prime sponsor if he had
um given any consideration to cost
benefit
analysis and he said
no and so I have prepared an amendment
to address what I think is a shortcoming
of the bill and we'll pass that out to
everyone
so what this amendment does basically is
it just adds a new section
two under
duties which requires the committee to
perform and publish rigorous cost
benefit analyses of all programs and
then describes a couple of different
use representative Thomas's name is
first on this
amendment which is an OSS error
because I was the one who um created the
amendment but it doesn't matter comes
from our caucus so doesn't have the
water ma unapproved
either oh yeah interesting happens now
it doesn't have the unapproved watermark
on it like like most uh amendments do I
don't know what that means um
another change is on line 22 section 4
seek Partnerships with there was already
a couple of entities mentioned and we uh
added a bunch more clean energy New
Hampshire the Sierra Club the
conservation law Foundation Granite
outdoor Alliance Nature conserv Boy
Scouts of America Girl Scouts of the USA
America
um
two line
three Section 8 develop a sustainable
member recruitment strategy that does we
added the words that does not interfere
with State business economic
interests which may be redundant based
on representative wilhelm's testimony
that the
um leg Federal legislation that
authorized
the American Service Corp
prohibits groups formed Under the
Umbrella of that legislation to
interfere with Economic and Business
interests but u i felt it was worthwhile
to restate that in in this
legislation so comments on the
legislation representative Ms um more of
a more of a question the um
you know the items that you included in
the new section to the cost benefit
ratio and the cost Effectiveness
analysis
um those those would be done on a on a
kind of um projected basis correct
because all that we're proposing here
all that the bill proposes is to put
together a plan on how we might
implement this kind of program there
won't be any actual costs or benefits to
calculation well if you propose a
program and you determine that the
program presents
benefits isn't it incumbent upon you to
also
calculate what the delivery of those
benefits will cost that's the essence of
a cost benefit analysis no I I agree
with you I just want to make sure that
we're all clear that what we're talking
about are project
benef costs and benefit yes of course
yes
okay there was one other change that I
forgot to mention on line four number
one the very first word in the original
legislation is
shape and I changed that to Define
because I I couldn't understand exactly
what shape meant so I thought Define was
a was a better a choice of words
representative Wendy Thomas thank you um
on page one lines 22 through 24 where
you identify the groups that they should
seek Partnerships with you're not
implying that those are the only groups
there yes I I never meant to uh exclude
any any other proposed organizations um
I just thought that those since those
are organizations that we hear from
Fairly regularly in this committee would
be yeah I understand that but the way
it's written it looks like those are the
only organizations they can link arms
with it it does sort of look that way
maybe we can address that um thank
you shortcoming in the senate
representative Corman yeah thank you um
so one one suggestion would be just say
Seek Partnerships with organizations
such as and then that list uh but I had
another question which is um so in lines
12 through 19 there are listed two
specific methodologies and I'm just
wondering why two specific methodologies
need to be included in the bill when
examples because it would be too long to
include a list of all of the uh cost
benefit analyses I did a um a
preliminary SE Arch and found 10
different methodologies that you could
use to do a cost benefit analysis and I
chose the two that I thought would be
most appropriate for this particular
Target um if if I may um but so then
you're not excluding some other accepted
methodology are you you're not reing one
of these two says using an accepted
methodology for example so it doesn't
preclude others no right so I'm just
wondering can could could we just end
then someone would inevitably raise the
question well what kind of methodology
are you're talking about so I put a
couple in here to give examples so
people would know just exactly what
about more information is better than
than less
right partial information can be more
damaging than than none I mean I'm I'm
not against these two please please
understand I'm just thinking you know as
a word Smith here just where where we
list two and you said there are 10 that
that could be used so you know these two
were chosen
um it it it seems to me
like either you list them all or none
that that's the way I would do it well
as I look through the list of 10 there
were some that were I didn't think yeah
appropriate at all for this kind of a
cost benefit analysis so I chose the two
that I felt were were the were the best
fit and use them as examples but
not in a prescriptive way I didn't write
the language to say you have to use
these
two representative McGee I would like to
join this conversation
um so I I I'm coming back to two things
um first representative muns mentioned
the fact that these would be projected
cost benefit ratios or projected cost
effective analyses because they can't
know in advance of running the program
what the actuals would be so it will be
predicated on assumptions
and um and often times cost benefit
analysis will have quite a bit of
assumption um used in in making um the
cost benefit analysis so what I see here
though is you're defining each of these
even though those definitions are
readily available and then also adding
the goal shall be to identify the most
cost-effective option for achieving a
particular
objective and I don't think that this
bill lends itself to that this is not
the same as is running running a program
where it would be investment of State
dollars for a particular outcome like
weather Rising houses or whatever that
could be Quantified and I think the
testimony that we had um
yesterday went into sort of
the the generative benefits of
having programs that are young people
could participate in and the advantage
of getting them very hard to quantify
things like job experience and uh
camaraderie and whatever so I'm not I'm
not sure that um this much definition
needs to be put here in cost benefit
because there's no fiscal note on this
bill there's no money being put in that
we have to account for so I just think
it might be Superfluous or you could
list it as um my colleague uh
representative Corman mentioned which is
end at the comma after
methodology and then say for example
cost benefit
Ratio or cost Effectiveness analysis and
you don't have to put all the other
stuff in there so that people are at
least keeping it in mind but I'm not
sure what we gain from that like either
we're going to ask them to pursue it so
we can see how it works out or we're not
because we to spend anything so that
sentence that you referen the goal shall
be to identify blah blah blah that
sentence applies specifically to the
costeffective analysis it's part of the
description of that analysis it does
doesn't mean that the goal of all of the
cost benefit analyses should be to
identify the most cost effective option
let me let me put it this way it does it
make it too burdensome for the people
who are trying to implement is the would
be the question does it make it
burdensome because these are examples so
I don't see that it creates any kind of
a burden for the implementor because
they could choose a completely different
methodology if they
wanted I just thought it was it would be
useful MH to to prevent people from
wondering well what kind of a
methodology should I use to to cite a
examples well can I can I suggest that
we add projected in front of A and B
under examples because they wouldn't be
actual so insert the word projected
where before benefit cost ratio and cost
analysis so using an accepted
example how about if we put the word
projected perform and
publish
rigorous projected cost benefit proed
cost
that to do this right away H us to do
yep chrisy head going to give you a
heads up we're going to be asking you to
take uh some changes to
OS and try to get them accomplished as
quickly as possible I'll let you take my
copy so you you'll you'll have all
the yeah and you could also mention to
watermarked
okay Su representative
muns I I you know I was just going to
suggest that you know if rather than
maybe identifying the two specific
examples just use some wording like you
know wellestablished generally accepted
cost benefit analysis approaches I mean
there aren't that many many and rather
than confuse the issue by somehow
pointing them to these two when we
really don't
care that's just
suggestion representative
Summers thank you Mr chair um due to the
complexity of the discussion here and
looking at it the fact that it
establishes a study committee would this
not follow into the same Paradox at the
three prior bills before creating a
study committee for the this short
term yeah it It suffers from the same
problem and we discussed that in the
public hearing yesterday sorry you uh
couldn't couldn't join us but um it is a
pretty tight window
to to come up with a report on this
study committee by the 1st of November
2024 but representative willhelm who was
the Prime sponsor of the bill said he
thought it was doable so that's why
we we thought that it would it would
probably be okay to go forward with this
particular study
committee representative Corman thank
you uh I have a question uh for you
about the intent of the cost benefit
analysis um so I'm I'm thinking in
particular about the line the goal shall
be to identify the most costeffective
option for achieving a particular
objective and I understand that that is
to the ca methodology but just in terms
of your intent I'm imagining let's say
there were two Alternatives A and B um a
has a higher or better cost benefit
analysis but only by a little bit uh but
B has other
advantages would is your intent that you
would base something only on the cost
benefit analysis or you would factor
that in with the other advantages that a
program might have and I'm asking this
because you know people often ask well
what was the intent of the legislation
so I just want to understand your
intent so this is a study committee and
this is a task for the committee to
duties
therefore the goal of this task is to
make sure that they do a cost benefit
analysis
it's one thing as I mentioned a few
minutes ago to list all the benefits of
doing
something but if you exclude the costs
then how can you make a rational
decision
about what option to choose so the goal
of this duty is to get them to do some
kind of rational cost benefit analysis
on the options they're
considering simple as that right so so
I'm that I understood and I think that
makes perfect sense uh the the question
really was would that be the the only
Criterion that that should be used to
decide about a program or would there be
other criteria taken into account as
well well under duties there's a whole
list of things that the study committee
should be evaluating as it tries to
develop a plan for one of these programs
and I'm just saying that a cost benefit
final thought representative McGee his
his comment brought up this thought so
having these descriptions here these are
the general descriptions for benefit
cost ratio and cost Effectiveness
analysis and so they are based on uh
general principles around determining
cost
Effectiveness the number two item says
perform and publish and I'll say a
projected cost benefit analysis of all
programs using an accepted methodology
when you put these particulars in here I
think it may
modify uh the committee's thoughts
around what it is their their their
required um to return when it's
prospective right this bill is they're
not going to have anything much real to
work with so I just I don't think we
should spend time trying to identify um
the detailed language that comes after
these definitions because I think it's
it convolutes the issue more I think if
you just left number two saying perform
and publish a a projected cost benefit
analysis of all programs using an accept
using accepted methodologies that that
would be sufficient I don't I don't
think I think the other language just um
May confuse folks as to what they have
to achieve to meet it since it's going
in
law I'm having trouble understanding
what's offensive about a couple of
examples well the BCR greater than one
indicates the benefits exceed the costs
and to representative corman's point in
some cases the benefits will not be
quantifiable in terms of a number and so
it's in the eye of the beholder and it
just makes it a little harder for a
BCR methodology correctly I think that
it would come out out the way you
want if BCR turned out to be greater
okay I think the fewer changes we ask OS
to make at this point in time the better
off we're going to be because it's now
quarter of
two
so Christy could you come and get this
uh and take it to OS please and ask them
to make two changes ask them to make add
the word projected after rigorous in on
line 10 and ask them to change online 22
insert the the the phrase organizations
such
as okay and the uh Watermark or whatever
it's
called
98 as I indicated in my testimony
yesterday I have authored an
amendment to this
bill which removes section one of the
bill and changes the wording of the
section in section two of the bill it
also changes
um section two of the bill to to now
bill so basically this amendment
replaces the entire Bill and as you can
see shortens it by well over
half so now the bill has just one
section except for the effective date
section that's that's section number
two
and that just says that we insert a new
paragraph 7A after paragraph 7 in RSA
362a colon 9 that reads distribution
utilities shall recover costs associated
with net metering and group hosting
through a stranded cost recovery charge
or other non bypassable charges approved
by the commission as long as those
charges are displayed on customer bills
that's the same wording that that I
offered in my written testimony
yesterday when I introduced this bill
and so we would be my caucus will offer
this amendment to
1398 and a motion of ought to pass as
amended so comments on this
amendment so Mr
chairman um so you're suggesting that
after section section s there now be a
section 7 a so it's distinct it doesn't
replace anything correct okay it's a new
section
okay any other comments on
this proposed
amendment representative
nter I appreciate that it's shorten to
the
good um representative McGee yep um I
thought when we spoke
earlier the amendment was going to not
use stranded recovery cost charge but
was going to use the same nomenclature
as unitel was using I have it written
down somewhere in my notes but didn't
you say it was going to be called the
same thing in in order to eliminate it
from being construed as a stranded cost
which was kind of the sticking point so
the phrase or other non- bypassable
charge as approved by the commission
means it could be an extra external
Unitil and the only sort
of
uh policy change would be that this
language would require that that charge
would be displayed on customer bills
which it currently is not so for Unitil
this would require adding their external
distribution charge as a listing on the
bill I I would prefer honestly if we're
going to get it right I would prefer if
the sentence said distributed utilities
shall recover costs associated with net
metering and group hosting through a non
bypassable charge rather than mentioning
all
as long as the charge is displayed on
customer bills
yes because I think even ever Source uh
testified to the fact that it would be
confusing to construe these charges
which are associated with rates in the
in the stranded recovery section of the
testimony too bad we already sent chrisy
off to
uh true we have other work to do she can
suppose any other comments on this while
I think about that
um Mr
chair representative
bernardy so I believe the the discussion
for including it in the stranded cost
line along with other stranded
cost was was to because it's already
line on the bills that exist and
therefore one would not be requiring a
new line to be printed uh on bills and
re incur the cost of of correcting a a
bill template
um
so the other virtue of putting it in
that place
was then it was a common place where
everyone who is interested in it could
say in my stranded costs what
are the net metering charges what are
the uh costs associated with whatever
so so representative
McGee how would you like this
language distribution utility shall
recover cost associated with net group
hosting through a non bypassable charge
such as stranded cost recovery Char such
as a stranded cost recovery charge as
approved by the commissioner as long as
those charges are displayed on the
bills again I think they have the option
whichever and I'm rattling
off um I I I still believe that rather
than giving them stranded cost recovery
charge in in what we're changing we
should say through a non- bypassable
charge which the stranded recovery cost
is a subset of a non- bypassable charge
and that way it leaves the option open
rather than leading them there because
we did have testimony that it would be
confusing if that was if that was where
we put it that and that was eversource
so I I don't think I don't think we
should be leading them there
um and they still have the option
certainly uh we did get testimony that
right now the stranded recovery costs
are um where they're putting that so
that to to your point JD right that
right right oh you're here I don't want
but did he move
up is the way are you dying to join this
anyway that that's my point I I'm not
sure I'm not sure we need that language
in here in order to um to cover what it
is we're trying to cover with the Pu
because they know what the non-
bypassable charges are and they know
which ones are appropriate without us
defining
it well to be honest with you I'm I
really don't object to taking that
stranded cost recovery charge language
out through
charge as approved by the commission as
long as those charges are displayed on
customer
bills so we can make it even shorter and
briefer which would make representative
nter happy to everyone
suarin all right as soon as christe gets
back or she we have one of us go over
this representative
Corman thank you uh I have to say that
even if if it's shorter I'm I'm not in
favor of this bill for a couple of
reasons one is that things are fluid
right now and we have an open docket at
the puc about net metering and things
are going to be
changing and uh there's still nothing
about the advantages of net metering
that would be appearing on a customer
bill
um plus all the concerns raised by uh Mr
Belo um many of which um were confusing
but uh you know and remain to be
understood but but you know he he
clearly had some some real concerns
about how this would affect Community
power and other aggregators so um even
with the change I I won't be voting for
this okay that's perfectly fine
representative muns
um I I have a question and um forgive me
if I should know the answer but we you
know is if if this bill if if this bill
passes and we add this language to
statute is that going would would that
be the first time in statute that we are
saying that net metering may be
recovered through a non- bypassable
charge the first time in Statute in
statute I know the Pu has said that we
can do it but would this be the first
reference in statute to making it a non-
bypassable charge that be a good
question for OS research I was hoping
that maybe Mr Lata could give us some
insight or putting him on the spot yet
Roberge that's what maybe we can get an
answer to that before before the after
is over that that to me is a is a would
be a big concern so representative
Bernard has a comment yeah I'm it's my
belief that this is just a transparency
issue this is not not uh um making any
comment whether a charge is recoverable
or not recoverable the the the uh the
costs exist the charges exist it's just
a transparency issue of making sure it's
captured and available for
understanding representative Thomas Doug
Thomas has a thank you Mr chair I just
want to say that um uh I'm I'm not
entirely coni I'm not sure if Mr
bow accurately addressed the bill to his
concerns as far as what this bill is
really doing so I'm I'm not sure I I can
agree with uh with much of what he said
regarding what he thought this bill
would do I think this is a transparency
issue um I think it makes the bill
better and um I can I I can support the
bill by supporting this amendment which
I think makes the bill
better thank you uh representative rolds
has a
comment thank you Mr chairman I um I
appreciate that you were willing to uh
accept R representative McGee's um
suggestion that we delete reference to
uh
labeling net metering
costs stranded costs because I think
that's that would be entirely
inappropriate net metering costs do not
fit the definition of stranded costs so
I'm glad we we got that far but I I
uh object to the continued
characterization of this bill as a
transparency bill when uh what it would
do is it would it seems to me that it it
kind of is is another volley in our
ongoing you know battle over the
discussion of the costs and benefits of
net
metering of which you know we talked we
discussed yesterday about the deer study
multi-year study about the costs and
benefits of net metering and in this
bill you are attempting kind of an end
naming the costs of net metering as a
cost and remaining silent on the
benefits of net metering and now we're
going to put a number on customers bills
that tell them that there is this cost
to net metering while remaining silent
about the benefits of net metering and
we had testimony yesterday that that
said as much um by being
one-sided uh it's not not transparent
it's actually muddling the issue so I
object to uh the amendment and the bill
and won certainly won't be voting for it
representative liwicki okay just uh I
think that there is a parallel between
this and the uh decades old construction
work in prog uh line on the uh utility
bills which brought the attention of the
rate payers to the fact that uh they
were paying for something and were not
getting an immediate benefit so there's
a lot I think there's a parallel I think
precedent representative
migie well I must apologize because I am
getting old but I did actually watch the
hearing I rewatched some of Clifton
belo's testimony as well and um because
I had nothing better to do this morning
and uh my memory has been jogged by the
stuff that other folks are saying and
one of the things that was of concern is
that what this enables is not simply an
effort at transparency but also to sort
of enshrine the ability for net metering
costs to be recovered for utilities but
it doesn't offer that same um uh
security to anybody else that's
operating in the competitive markets and
therefore it puts those
competitive uh generate suppliers at a
disadvantage so there there are aspects
to this simple change that may have
economic impacts which um could
seriously hamper that competition so I
think I won't be voting for it either
amend it or otherwise okay
representative muts thank you um I I'd
just like to respond to you know
representative Bernard's comments and
and some others as well that you know
the way the bill the way this amendment
is worded it's it's more than just
transparency I mean it I mean if you
read the first first four words in the
in the amendment it says distribution
utilities shall recover costs associated
with net metering so and as we learned
this morning shall means it's a mandate
so this is this is putting in statute a
mandate that uh net metering costs can
be recovered through a standard a
stranded cost uh mechanism if it was
purely um for transparency's sake we
would use language such as to the extent
a utility purchases you know net
metering they may they may you know
definitive that's a good point but if
you change shall to May
then that allows them to continue to
recover net ring costs through race
which buries them and makes them
difficult to
track and destroys any kind of
transparency that you would have into
those rates so that's the reason the
word shall was preferred over may could
I representative months yeah could I
just you know respond to that I mean
what we could do and I'm not saying that
I would necessarily support it but just
you know what we could do is take out
the language it talks about shall
recover costs associated with net
metering
take take out the the the language that
says they that utility shall recover
costs and just say utility
shall disclose any net metering costs
that they have
incurred as a St as a um stranded cost
recovery
charge if all you're worried of all
transparent but that changes the
definition of what a stranded cost
recovery charge is for correct it's not
for disclosing it's
for capturing charges that the utility
has incurred that it can't recover in
means I see your point but but that fix
won't work I don't
think but I appreciate the uh the
suggestion representative
Bernardi yes utilities recover these
costs no matter matter what so that
isn't the issue the issue is the display
or the availability to to see them so if
they if it's if it's buried in the rates
they're recovered or if it's or if it's
pulled out as a non- bypassable charge
it it's there so it's a transparency
issue that's the predominant focus of
this
bill representative
re thank you Mr chairman uh the larger
point the much more significant
policy well point an economic point that
former commissioner former
representative Belo made in his
testimony yesterday is that is the
anti-competitive nature and the fact
that it would be a reversal a
backtracking on the policy and
principles of
restructuring and it would
undercut by authorizing the regular Rel
ated utilities to quote recover their
costs of net metering it would
disadvantage the competitive suppliers
and the um Community
power
providers it would increase their cost
so this would this is counter to you
know more than stated so more than a
decade of Pol of of policy okay so we
have reached the end of our work session
is now 2:00 so we're going to have to
move on to our executive
session so I'm gonna ask
um Christie when she comes back she left
right now we're ex she
will make a further change to this
amendment and hopefully we'll get that
back before we get to it but in the
meantime we can move on to an executive
session representative Wendy Thomas did
you have a question thank you no it's
just a comment I'm waiting to uh be
called into another room to testify so I
may have to leave at some point I'm just
waiting to
hear okay what time are you scheduled um
it's supposed to start at 2:15 uh from
what I understand there's quite a few
people lined up so I've asked the the
chair to put me as the last speaker so
it could be okay I'm just letting you
know there there's a
chance
159 yeah really okay no problem we're
all good okay so we're that's not an
issue then right okay all right that
being the case then Mr chair I know
we're going to get to voting so yes
representative McGee just one final
question on 1398 and the amendment um
we've brought up the issue of an unfair
advantage in having only the utilities
be able to recover the net metering
costs and
so is there any answer here among our
committee as to whether we would be
committing that offense with this appeal
because we should know before we vote on
it shouldn't we well it's not clear to
me that that's the case based on what
the honorable Clifton Belo told us
yesterday it Bears further examination I
agree um but since we schedule this exec
session for
today I'm going to suggest that we pass
this bill and when it gets to the
Senate that issue can be addressed in
the
Senate and we know that uh Clifton Boo
has a good relationship with several
members of the Senate so I'm sure he'll
be able to address those issues promptly
if he'd have brought him to my attention
before yesterday we might have had time
to deal with this in time for us to deal
you know make changes here in this
committee but he didn't do that so
um we'll see where it goes if this is
our last chance to speak before we just
have to say yay or nay then no we'll
have a debate we we will yeah typically
in exec sessions remember we make a make
a motion on the floor and then we
discuss it okay
so all right
so I'm going to open an exact session on
House Bill
1047 relative to establishing a
committee to study the effectiveness of
State Outreach to Residents without
computer access and I'm going to
recognize representative Doug Thomas for
a
motion okay uh yes uh Mr chair uh I move
to U recommend adoption of amendment U
2024 -
99h on HB
1047 so you move ought to pass as
amended with amendment
first now the clerk tells me that's not
the way you do it the clerk says the
motion is ought to pass as
amended and then you offer the
amendment and if the amendment passes
then the the motion of ought to pass as
amended also passes I agree Mak that's
the way the clerk told me it's supposed
to work that makes sense Christie yes if
you
moved okay so it's moved and uh chair
recognized that repres resentative
Summers I second the motion moved and
seconded that we
adopt House Bill
1047 as amended
by amendment
number
2024-the um I just would like to speak
in support of this saying that that it's
an important and timely effort and we
need to um get this information and
quantify it and see how we can get
Communications out to everyone thank
you thank you and with a little bit of
luck uh passing it this early in the
session it'll get to the governor's desk
like maybe in May so maybe we we can get
this uh effort going in time to get a
decent report by November 1st
representative Gman do we did we have a
second on the amendment do we need a
second on the
amendment
amendment okay but do we need a second
on the amendment specifically
no it's a
joint
um it's a joint motion ought to pass as
amended by amendment number blah blah
blah so so you you that's the motion and
then you second that entire motion
that's the way the clerk told me it's
supposed to work
discussion well seeing none I'm going to
ask the clerk to call the role on the
question of ought to pass as amended by
amendment number
Clerk repr reprentative Doug Thomas yes
representative Janine ner yes
representative Michael Harrington yes
representative John lewicki yes
representative Lex Bry yes
representative JD Bernardi yes
representative Tom PL yes representative
James Summers yes Representative Steven
Kennedy yes representative cat McGee yes
representative Rebecca McWilliams yes
representative Jackie cre yes
representative Lucius parall yes
representative Tony kaplan's not here
representative Chris muns yes
representative Henry
Noel yes representative Wendy Thomas yes
representative Thomas Corman yes
representative Ned rolds yes
190 okay by a vote of 19 to
nothing House Bill HB
1047 is judged to be worthy of a to pass
as amended by Amendment 2024
0099 H since it was a unanimous vote is
there any uh um objection to putting it
on the consent calendar no
is uh representative Thomas um I have
Thomas I have a question for the chair
uh under this procedure of voting uh
otpa in the
future what in the past we've known
people that would vote for the amendment
but then wouldn't vote for the actual
otpa how is that how would that be
handled under the procedure that that we
just
did good
question not sure the answer for that
that's F sure the answer to that when we
were taught this we were taught that we
had to do the amendment separately and
then the then the amendment the you know
the bill as amended but the clerk I know
he gave you different instructions so I
I'm
well maybe we'll go back to doing it the
old way then just to be just to be safe
I
don't perhaps to cover us we should just
take a second vote just to cover
us all representative
N I agree I I would agree but but but
the vote was 19 to zero so I don't see
why we should use the time and I agree
with representative n yeah if it's if
it's the consensus then fine we can make
no
that all right is there any objection to
the committee to letting the vote as we
just took it
stand no Mr chairman I I would suest we
will shift our our methodology for this
I suggest if we are aware that it's
non-c contentious we should we could go
to the otpa because there wouldn't be
any any opposing vote to log but if if
we know that we're not all in agreement
then maybe we should do the two-step
process so that it's on
record but then the question would would
be do we always know that exactly
exactly
so yeah we did but okay representative
Wendy Thomas no I was just going to say
let's standardize the pro the process
and let's just vote on the the amendment
before any I mean just standardize it
then we'd have nothing to
discuss yes we will do that for the rest
of the uh exec session
bills all right so close the exact
1047 and open an EXA exact session on
hb1
1230 and I
recognize representative Michael
Harrington for a motion yeah I move uh
itl on HB 1230
zero chair recognizes representative n
second it's moved and seconded that we
resolve that hb1
1230 is inexpedient to legislate is
discussion representative MC
Williams thank you chair Vose um I just
want to note for the record that um it's
difficult to do a study bill in the
second year um and I do think that there
were a lot of underlying good ideas in
this bill um so perhaps it's something
that we could consider bringing forward
in uh the following house session thank
you okay thank you by the way
representative McGee it just occurred to
me uh representative cap Kaplan is
absent do we know anything about that uh
he's testifying I believe he had he's
here but he had a hear he had a hearing
in another room he's the
spons do we want to suspend any votes
until he gets
back anything that's your call I mean
yeah anything that might be contentious
I would think we
would I I don't I don't think this one
it well if we could skip that great does
anybody have any idea when he might be
can
I think I saw a message that he's
hour if you if you could just drag him
over here for five minutes we can take
this vote he can he can register his
back I'm sorry I didn't recogn I his
absence uh before we took the vote on
if
where is Commerce meeting do you
know
okay
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker Mr chairman
question yes I I realize we try to get
as many people here as possible but this
is a scheduled meeting if someone
chooses to be some Poli Sal I don't see
how we can accommodate that based on
other hearings otherwise we'll never get
this done because there's a possibility
anytime we schedule a hearing they could
be in a hearing someplace else person's
going to have to make a decision that
they can always submit written testimony
and be here but I don't think we should
all sit around and wait whether it's a
Republican or a Democrat we're waiting
for it just isn't fair to the rest of us
to have to sit here because someone
chooses to be someplace else they should
submit written testimony and be here
this is their first priority this is the
committee they member
of now you make a really good point
there representative Harrington so we'll
wait until representative Thomas comes
back and then we'll proceed we'll
continue whether she has representative
not
okay so it has been moved and seconded
that we resolved that hb1
1230 is inexpedient to
legislate is there any further
discussion seeing none I ask the clerk
to call the role on the question of itl
1230 representative Doug
Thomas
yes representative Janine ner yes
representative Michael Harrington yes
represent John lewicki yes
representative Lex Bry yes
representative jie Bernardi yes
representative Tom PL yes representative
James Summers yes Representative Steven
Kennedy yes representative cat McGee yes
representative
Rebecca Rebecca
McWilliams pardon my tongue twisting I
want to say
no what we didn't hear
I'm gonna say no all right thank you for
producing my produc pronouncing my name
right I can't speak either I give up
representative Jackie cran no
representative Lucius parshall no
representative Tony Kaplan
no representative Chris muns reluctantly
yes representative Henry
Noel yes representative Wendy Thomas no
representative Thomas Corman
no represent representative Ned
rolds representative chairman
Vose
yes okay
so one two three four five
six uh
146 by a vote of 14 to six
the the motion of itl is
adopted and representative Harrington
will write the majority report will
there be a Minority Report yes who was
it yeah wheny you either either me or
Tony or representative Kaplan okay one
of us will do it okay whoever plans to
write The Minority Report please have it
done by Thursday this coming Thursday at
the close of business
representative Corman thank you I have
two questions one for the clerk um I
counted only five no votes so could you
tell me who the M Williams cran partiall
Kaplan Wendy Thomas Corman so I thought
uh representative cran had voted yes no
she voted oh okay my bad and then I had
a second question which was um on the
previous Bill
representative Doug Thomas will write
committee okay I guess we're done with
HB 230 so I close the exec session on
that
bill and I will now open an exec session
on House Bill 1289 I was going to tell
representative Tony cap that he's free
to go but I see he's already left he
flew he flew Kaplan has left the
building or at least left the room all
right so House Bill 1289 establishing a
commission to study the replacement of
the peer plant in bow with a clean
energy base load generator and storage I
recognize Representative Steven
Kennedy thank you Mr chairman uh I'd
like to make a motion to itl House Bill
1289 I recognize is representative McGee
and I'd like to second that motion it's
moved and seconded that we resolve to
judge hb2
28289 as inexpedient to legislate is
discussion seeing none I ask the clerk
to call the role on the question of it
1289 representative Doug Thomas
yes repres representative Janine ner yes
representative Michael Harrington yes
representative John lewicki yes
representative Lex Bry yes
representative JD Bernardi yes
representative Tom PL yes representative
James Summers yes Representative Steven
Kennedy yes representative cat McGee yes
representative Rebecca McWilliams
yes okay yes representative Jackie crean
yes representative Lucius parshall yes
representative Tony Kaplan is
absent representative Chris muns yes
representative Henry Noel yes
representative Wendy Thomas yes
representative Thomas Corman yes
representative Ned rolds yes re
representative chairman
Bose
yes
nothing hb1
1289 is judged to be inexpedient to
legislate without objection we'll put it
calendar hearing no objection ctions it
consent and Representative Steven
Kennedy will write the committee report
and I need that by Thursday afternoon at
close of close of
business is that that okay under and
understood representative Kennedy yes
okay all
right so that closes the public hearing
on I mean the uh executive session on HB
1289 now if I can find the amendment for
1499 which I somehow manag to the new
approv yeah the new approv oh maybe we
don't have it yeah that's it because I
gave the old one to that's why I can't
find it I gave that to Christie so I
brief no we have an amendment for that
one
too so it looks like we're going to have
to wait for a little while so let us uh
take a brief
break a bio break or whatever a stretch
break and we'll be back as soon as these
available
okay ladies and Gentlemen let's get back
to
work
y
from OLS we have a couple of
amendments so we're going to move on to
some exec
sessions I'm going to open an exec
session on House Bill
1499 establishing a committee to study
the civilian clean energy Community re
resilience and conservation core and I
will make a move a motion of ought to
H and I'll recognize representative Doug
Thomas
second representative Doug Thomas
seconds the motion on the movement of
event amendment
02h I I have the original that I sent to
OS and I'm now going to verify that it
matches what we asked them to do so on
line 10 they inserted the word projected
in front of cost benefit
analysis and on line
22 they
inserted the words organizations such
as which is exactly what we asked them
to do so this um Amendment appears to be
and it says unapproved what we uh what
we wanted is there any further
amendment representative MC Williams
just a question on the amendment usually
we have um a representative's name for
who the drafter or who was supporting
amendment
I don't think it needs a name it has a
number um and it's basically a committee
Amendment so I'm not sure it needs a
name so yeah representative
representative Mick Williams did you
have a further
comment that was it I just wanted to
know whose name it was
under
okay all right any further comments on
this
amendment all right seeing none I'll ask
the clerk to call the role on the
question of ought to pass on Amendment
02h representative Doug Thomas yes
representative Janine n
reluctantly yes representative Michael
Harrington yes representative John
liwicki yes representative Lex Bry yes
representative JD Bernardi yes
representative Tom PL yes representative
James Summers yes Representative Steven
Kennedy yes representative cat McGee yes
representative Rebecca
McWilliams yes representative Jackie
crean yes representative Lucius parall
yes representative Tony Kaplan yes
representative Chris muns yes
representative Henry Noel yes
representative Wendy Thomas yes the
representative Thomas Corman yes the
representative Ned rolds yes
representative chairman
Zer by vote of 20 to zero the amendment
2024 01
02h is adopted I now move ought to pass
as amended on HB
1499 and recognize representative Thomas
Doug Thomas second moved and seconded
that we resolved that HB
1499 should be determined to be ought to
2024-25
please
and while he's getting ready I will
thank all members of the committee
for your diligent work in helping to
develop this amendment and the other
today okay representative Doug Thomas
yes representative Janine ner
no representative Michael
Harrington yes representative John
liwicki
yes representative Lex bney
no representative JD Bernardi yes
representative Tom blog yes
representative James Summers yes
Representative Steven Kennedy yes
representative C McGee yes
representative Rebecca McWilliams yes
representative Jackie crean yes
representative Lucius parshall yes
representative Tony Kaplan yes
representative Chris muns yes
representative Henry Noel yes
representative Wendy Thomas yes
representative Thomas Corman yes
representative Ned rolds yes
182 okay by a vote of 18 2 HB 1499 is
resolved to be worthy of ought to pass
as amended by 2024 0102 H you want to go
on the announce consent it will not go
on the consent calendar since there were
some members who voted in
majority report is there going to be a
Minority
Report
oh I know I don't want it I can no
Minority Report
okay
Report all right with that we'll close
the executive session on HB
day where did the um copies disappear
to you you have it you handed it I just
have
mine anybody else have a little one did
I inadvertently hand out both this
amendment and the last last one at the
same time yes you did I did yeah I
didn't keep one for myself does anybody
extra yes it's Amendment
03h
does everybody have a copy of the
amendment were there any more
H all right so I'm going to open a
public hearing on I mean a executive
session on HB
1398 relative to utility recovery of
cost associated with net energy metering
and I'm going to move a to
Harrington I'll second that moved and
seconded that we resolved that HB
1398 is worthy of a to pass and I offer
Amendment
0103 H and recognize representative
Harrington move ought to
pass you second I moved the the motion
you second it okay it's moved and
seconded that we adopt the amendment
03h additional
discussion well the
uh the new Amendment does change the
wording as we
requested by
removing the phrase standard cost
recovery charge so it now says
distribution utilities shall recover
costs associated with net metering of
group hosting through a non- bypassable
charge as approved by the commission as
long as those charges are displayed on
customer
bills so that is the the amendment
representative McGee I I have a question
um how does passing this bill create any
difference from what is happening on
customer bills today because we keep
talking about how we're doing it in
service of transparency but I think
right now net metering charges are being
recovered under a non- bypassable charge
whether it's um the stranded cost charge
or other and they appear on the
customer's bill but the customer Custer
still has to call the utility if they
want to understand those charges they're
not they're not spelled out anywhere so
anything so the way that this
bill changes the current um current
policy is that it requires that those
nonb bypassable charges be displayed on
customer Bills currently Unitil does not
display their external distribution
charge on their customer bills but they
use that charge to recover net metering
costs does that answer your question yes
and um the other question that I would
follow on with that I think came out of
the hearings that we should address or
at least understand is what effect this
would have on the the energy Market in
New Hampshire the the competitive energy
Market in New Hampshire in terms of
providing an advantage to the the um
default utilities
that is not being offered to anyone else
market that was
a question that was asked about the bill
during the course of the public hearing
and that question was never thoroughly
answered and probably requires further
study okay and based on that I w't won't
be able to vote for the amendment
representative Harrington yeah just
maybe I can clarify that just a little
bit presently at least like for ever
Source the charge is in the distribution
rate which is non bypassable because
everybody that's in ever Source customer
regardless of whether they get from
competitive supplier a default service
rate however they get their power they
pay that in the in the rate so it's not
going to be an advantage or disadvantage
to competitive suppliers because it's
still something that doesn't affect the
Energy Service rate which the Energy
Service rate is what people compete on
that's what you when you go to someone
like Direct Energy or whoever uh you're
looking at the Energy Service rate and
it'll say a certain cost but that cost
doesn't include this one way or the
other either now or would this bill
passed it still wouldn't
so so I have a have a question maybe
that go Ahad representative Harrington
could answer for me then so why is net
metering being called out as opposed to
any other form of
energy it's just a separate charge that
was decided to bring out that way
they'll have to ask the sponsor of the
bill on that what I'm saying is it has
no effect on someone that goes out as a
competitive supplier because they're
only competing on the energy and the way
it is right now it's either in the
stranded cost recovery which is non-
bypassable or it's part of the
distribution rates which is non-
bypassable just the I think the
distribution rate is obviously made up
of a whole mess of stuff where the
stranded cost recovery is
maybe three or four different items
that's the ma major
discuss representative Tony
Kaplan just to further you know the
question further along those lines from
what I understood from the discussion
that we had in in the work session
yesterday this stranded cost uh recovery
mechanism which is already in play
allows the uh the the the default
utility ities to recover their costs in
a way that it would not allow
competitive suppliers to recover their
cost they don't have that mechanism so
they're not recovering the same costs
they're not recovering the totality of
what they're
paying correct or or not but that is the
reality of
how the law exists today and this
amendment or this bill doesn't seek to
change
that just seeks to change how the
information is provided to customers so
while what the honorable honorable Mr
Belo was saying may be true this bill
was never trying to fix that in the
first place that requires a different
fix and presumably that's a fix that
he's working on
elsewhere but it's not really relevant
to this bill bill this bill is strictly
a bill to try to make net metering costs
more transparent by putting them on a
customer bill in a form that the
customer could use to to uh discover
more
about those
costs yeah I mean I agree that that is
the the the Practical effect that this
bill uh is making but by providing this
language and statute it it strengthens
that mechanism Le Al and it locks it in
as as the mechanism that the default
service providers are allowed to use uh
which makes it harder to then row it
back which is you know someone might be
trying to do that but it's it's once we
put it in statute it it becomes the law
of the land whereas now it's just they
that's how they're doing it because of a
pu order am I
right I'm not sure that you are right
about that but once again it's a
different problem the reason the word
shall is in there as we discussed and
maybe you word here for that um the work
session right before this um we started
our executive sessions is because
otherwise it wouldn't appear on customer
bills that's that's the key reason for
the word shall as opposed to
May in this in this language in this
sentence representative Ms thank you um
I I will be uh voting against this
amendment for precisely the reasons that
uh representative Kaplan just um
discussed
um you know this this bill if it passes
will put in statute as far as I know for
the first time the concept that net
metering costs can be recovered through
bypassable charges and we'll tie our
hands in terms of trying to address some
of the issues that I think there's
General agreement need to be addressed
um and so um given that uh I I fall back
on the old adage of um you know when in
doubt Do no harm so I will be uh voting
against this
amendment further discussion
representative Corman thank you um I
will be voting for the amendment but
against the bill whether amended or not
um I feel that the amendment at least
takes out the stranded cost part which I
feel is just not appropriate but um for
reasons I've stated before and don't
need to restate I just don't care for
the bill at
all representative leki uh thank you Mr
chairman um I think what we found is
coincident or incidental to what the
bill is and I wonder whether there's a
possibility of putting in a fix for net
metering in community power if there is
a fix possible in some other bill as an
amendment or uh whatever uh as we
proceed and that might be a way to get
something in this year but clearly there
is a glitch Community power is a
fledgling program and this is an
oversight apparently in uh how it was
set
up I can virtually guarantee there would
be a fix proposed in the Senate if this
bill got that far representative
rolds thank you Mr chairman uh I'm in
the same boat as my colleague
representative Corman I'm going to vote
for the amendment appreciating that we
intended to take out the labeling of uh
distribution uh sorry of uh cost of net
metering as as stranded cost but I I did
just want to ask a clarifying question
because um line three of of the
amendment still contains the the term
stranded cost recovery so I'm not sure
that's a problem because am I correct to
say that that it's only line five
through eight that becomes actual
legislation
but no I think that actually
is the title of the section of law that
this amendment is being applied to so
that that stranded cost recovery
mechanism language is already in the
section of law that this section is
being applied to okay so that is that is
existing statutory language line
three but lines five and through eight
are what will actually be uh inserted
and that language does not include
stranded costs the term stranded costs
so correct I think I'm okay with that
okay all right representative Doug
Thomas thank you Mr chair um yes um I'll
I will be voting for the amendment and
the bill because although I think the
bill uh
unintentionally uh highlighted an issue
we have with Community power that this
bill didn't seek to fix or or U or
address because that's a a different
issue but it actually did highlight an
issue uh and that can be fixed by by
some other method uh I think this bill
is uh as far as I can see
it the charges are already being charged
the customers are already paying for
them uh it becomes an issue of where do
they appear in the bill or in one case
even if even if it appears on your bill
this bill merely for transparency says
these charges will appear on your
electric
bill and it doesn't and to best my
knowledge does not cost the utilities to
to to do that it won't cost the
customers any more money and and does no
harm to anyone else so this is a very
straightforward transparency bill it's
like an accounting method moving a
charge from one column to the next for
transparency purposes and for more
clarity that's how I see it that's why
I'll be supporting
it representative Stephen Kennedy yeah
just to follow up uh thanks for
recognizing me just to follow up on what
doug was saying a lot of people are
talking about recovering costs as if
someone is paying the utility for these
costs they're not that it just goes into
the bill you know the customer is still
paying the cost and I don't understand
why the community thing would be any
different I mean you know they could pay
people to supply power through their
solar array and then they would you know
charge more or or whatever they decide
to charge uh their customers would be
how they recover that
cost so I I I you know I think you can
go either way on this but I I think it
is just an accounting mechanism it isn't
like somehow you know the the main
utilities get to recover their cost from
some magic fund or something and the
other guys don't I don't think it works
like that at
all representative migy okay so um
what's come up is where this is going to
be placed right the stranded cost
recovery mechanisms is under the
restructuring statute so it's specific
to default utilities but the language
that's here under 7A I think what uh the
question has been is if distributed
utilities are allow shall recover costs
associated with net metering and group
hosting then why wouldn't it be for all
all suppliers right so in other words
the statute here is under restructuring
so it only applies to you know what used
to be the monop Monopoly utilities and I
think the conversation yesterday
indicated that this could help take us
back in that direction rather than in
the direction that we've sort of
indicated we want to
go uh which is to inspire more
competition in order to create you know
choice for people and lower rates so I
still see it as two things the Pu docket
on the net metering tariff is unresolved
and I think that that's a major reason
why we should not be inserting something
here that um changes the way this
accounting works I think we will have
more answers when that docket is
resolved and so for that reason I will
also vote for the amendment because it
improves the original bill but I will be
voting against the bill
because I don't think we should be doing
this at this point without better
information and more clarity really
frankly on the entire committee as to
what it is that we're actually
discussion representative randles you
can turn off your mic now oh I'm sorry
um seeing none I'll ask the K clerk to
call the role on the question of
adoption of the amendment
representative Doug Thomas yes
representative Janine n yes
representative Michael Harrington yes
representative John liwicki yes
representative Lex py yes representative
JD Bernardi yes representative Tom PL
yes representative James Summers yes
Representative Steven Kennedy yes
representative cat McGee yes
representative Rebecca McWilliams
yes representative Jackie crean yes
representative Lucius parshall yes
representative Tony Kaplan yes
representative Chris muns yes
representative Henry Noel yes
representative Wendy Thomas yes
representative Thomas Corman yes
representative Ned rolds yes repres
20 Amendment adopted 20 to zero I now
move ought to pass as amended and
recognize representative Harrington
second that moved and seconded that we
adopt HB 1398 as op to pass as amended
by
20241 03h any further discussion
needed representative
Ms some of you may have noticed that I
changed my vote on that Amendment um
that's because I was persuaded by the uh
debate but I uh do intend to vote no on
the uh final
discussion seeing none I'll ask the
clerk as soon as he's ready
to call the role on the question about
amended representative Doug Thomas yes
representative Janine ner yes
representative Michael Harrington yes
representative John liwicki
yes representative Lex bery yes
representative JD Bernardi yes
representative Tom PL yes representative
James
Summers yes Representative Steven
Kennedy yes representative cat McGee no
representative Rebecca McWilliams no
representative Jackie crean no
representative Lucius parshall no
representative Tony Kaplan no
representative Chris muns no
representative Henry Noel no
representative w Thomas no
representative Thomas Corman no
representative Ned rolds no
representative chairman V yes 10
10 so by a vote of 10
to10 the motion about to pass as amended
fails I now offer the motion of refer
for interim study and recognize
representative Michael Harrington he
just left he just walked out oh we just
out sorry I recommend I uh
recognize representative McGee I'll
second that okay it's been moved and
1398 for interim study the reason I have
moved interim study is I don't want to
be responsible for sending to the house
floor for
debate with a without recommendation a
bill on net metering because I don't
want to watch my fellow house members
fall asleep listening to a debate that
understand so that's why I have moved
interim
study I do think this uh this issue will
surface again I virtually guarantee
it and uh I was pleased to hear rep
Representatives McGee and Corman uh
discussed earlier the fact that the open
currently open net metering docket might
be a good reason to avoid action on net
metering bills this session so we'll
take that under advisement and uh move
forward so is there any other discussion
on this motion representative Ms just a
just a question Mr chair can you remind
me refer to study what does that enable
us to
do so a motion of refer for interim
study enables the committee if it so
chooses to do some further study on the
bill it requires according to house
rules that by November 14th or something
I don't remember the exact date without
looking in the house calendar it
requires that we issue a
recommendation that says we recommend
this for further
uh legislation or we do not recommend
this for further legislation we have to
make that
judgment sometime in October or
November beyond that it's up to us to
decide as a committee if we want to
actually study the bill it's up to the
date of the
election up to the date of the election
okay up to the date of the next election
which is the first Tuesday of 2024 of
November 2024
further discussion representative Corman
uh just pertaining to your uh comment
about nit metering I do want to point
out I did introduce uh another bill on
net metering that Cliff Belo wrote uh
but I hope it will be a lot less
controversial it's just saying to treat
net metering as load reducers um so we
will be taking up one more net metering
bill at
least
correct any further
discussion
seeing none I'd ask the clerk to call
the role in the question of refer for
1398 representative Doug Thomas yes
representative Janine ner yes
representative Michael Harrington yes
representative John licki yes
representative Lex bney yes
representative JD Bernardi yes
representative Tom PL yes representative
James Summers yes representative stevenh
Kennedy yes representative cat McGee yes
representative Rebecca mck Williams
yes representative Jackie crean yes
representative Lucius parshall yes
representative Tony Kaplan yes
representative Chris muns yes
representative Henry Noel yes
representative Wendy Thomas yes
representative Thomas Corman yes
representative Ned rolds yes
representative chairman
Z by a vote of 20 to nothing this judge
this bill has been resolved to be turned
over for and referred for interim study
I will write
the uh committee report on the bill and
without objection I'll put it on the
consent
calendar hearing no objection this bill
will go on the consent
calendar I'll close the executive
1398 and that concludes our business for
today I would ask all members to keep an
eye on their email because we will be
scheduling committee work for next
Tuesday which is the 16th of
January I suspect there will be some
public hearings there may even be an
exec session on bills we heard earlier
today so pay particular attention to
your email does anyone else have any
matters that they would like to bring
before the committee representative
Wendy Thomas um yes just reminding you
that um the second half of the hearing
that we started today needs to be
scheduled
also yes that'll be done at some future
date but I can't when no just reminding
him okay thank
you just have a small announcement
representative McGee can we have a quick
caucus of the Democrats um before we
leave about future scheduling I just
second representative Thomas has a uh a
a comment he needs to make to the full
committee yes
um in conference with with the chair
um during exec session we we and there
will be probably other times when
members have to go out to um maybe the
the prime sponsor on a bill and they
have to go testify we
will Common cursy says that we will give
it our best shot to allow time for that
to happen in exec sessions uh with a a
reasonable time uh because we we want to
accommodate because we understand
there's a lot of things going on here uh
but there might be a case when um if you
cannot be here and we we're not going to
wait maybe an hour or half hour uh so we
we do want to try our best to to
accommodate and we did this afternoon
and I'm glad we did but just to let
people know that we uh we we understand
the issue uh we'll do our best to
accommodate but um the priority is to e
e execute here so please keep that in
mind but we will uh do our best because
we we try because we understand the the
you know
difficulty representative Bernardi has a
comment yes I I want to thank everybody
who participated in uh discussion on
1617 uh that's the uh uh first bill that
we took up today and I would appreciate
if anybody has any further thoughts or
comments send them to me is uh we either
going to craft an amendment here or
we're going to declare Victory and move
on I don't know
but but uh I I would appreciate any
comments that you have thank
you any any further comments before we
close our business representative Kaplan
yeah I just want to say uh thank you for
for you know uh trying to accommodate
the fact that I was Prime sponsoring
another bill at the same time it it was
not something that I had any control
over but I appreciate your your comments
representative Doug
Thomas okay thank you anything
else all right we're adjourned thank you
everybody good uh week's work see you
next
week